Moin, Leute.
Du bist jetzt auch wieder am Start.
Du bist auch immer pünktlich um 9 da, oder?
Ich glaube, ich habe dich die letzten paar Wochen schon immer hier pünktlich um 9 im Chat gesehen.
Und das schon bevor ich den Stream angemacht habe.
So, ist dann die Lautstärke richtig?
Ja.
Oh, Teams hat nichts an der Lautstärke rumgestellt.
Nice.
Ich hatte nicht gedacht, dass das geht.
Teams muss da aus Prinzip immer was dran rumstellen.
Tü-tü.
Moin, Battleship.
Gibt es eigentlich ein Browser-Plugin, was das hier ausblendet?
Was quasi den Browser Fullscreen macht, ohne ihn Fullscreen zu machen?
Also quasi das hier ausblendet?
Weil Fullscreen an sich ist doof.
Da sieht man hier unten nichts mehr.
Ich will aber eigentlich nur dieses Fenster aufhaben, ohne Leiste und den Rand.
Geht das?
Bestimmt.
Da gibt es bestimmt irgendwas.
Im Zweifelsfall geht das sogar ohne Plugin.
Dass man irgendwas an den Browser-Settings macht.
Kiosk-Mode, wie macht man den an?
Ne, Kiosk-Mode ist wahrscheinlich dann Fullscreen, oder?
Wie gesagt, das bringt ja nichts.
Naja, ist auch egal.
So wichtig ist das nicht.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Oder als PWA?
Da müsste man den Twitch-Chat als PWA machen.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
Dass man irgendwie sagt, irgendwie öffne als extra App.
Ich weiß, was du meinst.
Jaja, das wäre wahrscheinlich echt nicht verkehrt.
Wobei dann FFZ und so nicht funktioniert.
Man kann einfach den Rahmen um den Browser wegbekommen.
Da kann man halt so, muss doch gehen.
Geht ja offensichtlich im Fullscreen.
Jetzt bräuchte man halt nur Fullscreen, ohne Fullscreen zu sein.
Aber so immer.
Boah, ist das nicht so wichtig.
Würden halt ein paar Zeilen mehr auf den Bildschirm passen.
Moin, Unik.
HTML-Edit und Rand löschen.
Das geht ja schlecht.
Das hier ist ja nicht Teil von der Seite.
Das ist ja Teil vom Browser.
Wie geht's?
Ja, ganz gut.
Ich bin müde.
Obwohl ich schon fast, fast eineinhalb Stunden wach bin.
Aber ich habe nichts gemacht.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie das schon eineinhalb Stunden her sein kann.
Ich bin aufgestanden.
Ich bin aufs Klo gegangen.
Habe mich an den Rechner gesetzt.
Habe jetzt zwei Brötchen gegessen.
Das kann doch eigentlich keine eineinhalb Stunden gedauert haben.
Alles.
Ich habe mich auch nicht erst in meinen anderen Account eingeloggt, sondern direkt in den Streaming-Account gestartet.
Das heißt, hier irgendwie großartig was, großartig was aufgemacht, geguckt habe ich auch nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Abmahn.
Ach, ich habe Abmahn-Schmutz, Schmutz gelesen.
Ja, ist es wahrscheinlich auch.
Google-Fonts-Abmahnung verhindern.
Hey, ich wollte unter das Video einen Link posten zu einem Font-Projekt auf GitHub.
Also sprich, wie man sich die Fonts am besten selbst hosten kann.
Zumindest meiner Ansicht nach.
Aber ich habe einen GitHub-Link unter das Video gepostet und dann hat YouTube gesagt, nein, das ist Spam.
Das darfst du nicht posten.
Also ich durfte es posten, aber der Post war nicht da.
Dann habe ich es nochmal gepostet mit Leerzeichen zwischen den Links, äh, zwischen den Url, zwischen der Url, sodass es kein Link ist.
Und dann hat YouTube immer noch gesagt, nein, wird jetzt gesperrt.
Dann habe ich ihn mal gefragt auf Twitter, sag mal, kann sein, dass YouTube das gesperrt hat?
Und dann meinte er, er hat es noch nicht mal im Spam-Freigeben-Ordner drin in meinen Comment.
Also es war so böse, einen GitHub-Link zu posten in den YouTube-Comments, dass YouTube gedacht hat, das muss man auch nicht mal freischaltbar machen.
Ganz, ganz schlimm.
Ja, weil größere Content-Creator auf YouTube ja auch bekannt dafür sind, böse Links unter Videos von anderen Leuten zu spammen.
Ich weiß nicht, der YouTube-Algorithmus ist echt wild, wie man so schön sagt.
Es wäre mal an der Zeit für Algorithmen verstehen, den YouTube-Algorithmus zu erklären.
Aber ich glaube, da gerät er auch an seine Grenzen.
Weil ich vermute mal, selbst YouTube, die Leute, die das da weiterentwickeln, verstehen es nicht mehr.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die erste AI, die selbstständig geworden ist.
Keiner versteht mal den YouTube-Algorithmus.
Sie macht irgendwas, aber keiner weiß, warum.
Irgendwann, 2100, werden wir zurückgucken und sagen, mit dem YouTube-Algorithmus hat alles begonnen.
Oh, oh, wow.
MonkaS.
War ein großer Brötchen.
Nee, noch nicht mal.
Das waren so Tiefkühlbrötchen.
Ganz kleine Furzdinger.
Gibt es auf dem neuen PC Windows 11?
Das ist eine sehr gute, berechtigte Frage.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es dann auf dem neuen PC auch Windows 11.
Und da müssen wir uns wahrscheinlich mal in 1, 2 Streams der Sache widmen, dass man Windows 11 irgendwie usable machen kann.
Die nächste Frage.
Gibt es mittlerweile schon eine Möglichkeit, die Windows-Taskleiste, die Windows-11-Taskleiste, das Kopieren auszuschalten?
Irgendwelche Registry-Hacks oder so?
Also wenn ich jetzt hier beispielsweise Explorer starte mehrfach, ja, dann habe ich mehrfach Explorer am Start.
Das gibt es ja unter Windows 11 nicht mehr, weil Microsoft der Meinung ist, jeder möchte es unbedingt.
Ganz wichtig.
Auch wenn Microsoft wissen müsste, dass man mehr horizontalen Bildschirmplattformen,
als vertikalen, aber gut, Microsoft denkt, man muss das kopieren.
Nee, wenn, nee, nee, nee, ich will schon Windows 11 haben.
Auch weil viele neuen Sachen ja nur noch unter Windows 11 dann jetzt vielleicht noch nicht gehen, aber dann gehen werden.
Nee, es ist dann mal an der Zeit, neuer Rechner, neues, wenn das ist schon okay, dann wird es halt mal Windows 11.
Ist ja nicht so, als wäre Windows 11 so extrem viel unterschiedlich zu Windows 10.
Ja.
Wie geht es der Katz?
Das ist eine gute Frage, ich weiß nicht.
Die ist irgendwie...
Irgendwo liegt die jetzt und ich weiß nicht wo, keine Ahnung.
Also, heute Morgen ging es der noch gut, da ist die mir entgegen geflitzt.
Da musste ich mit ihr ins Bad, musste ihr den Wasserhahn anmachen,
weil meine Katze trinkt ja aus Prinzip am liebsten aus dem Wasserhahn
und tut so, als müsste verdursten, wenn ich den Wasserhahn nicht anmache.
Wohlgemerkt, die hat zwei Katzenbrunnen in der Wohnung verteilt, also im Haus verteilt
und Trinknäpfchen verteilt, aber die will trotzdem einen Wasserhahn.
Und wenn ich den Wasserhahn nicht anmache, dann ruft sie aus dem Bad so nach dem Motto
Auf jetzt hier, Alter, wird mal Zeit, mach mal an.
Ich bin hier am verdursten, Wasserhahn muss an.
Also, heute Morgen ging es der noch gut, jetzt geht der der wahrscheinlich auch noch gut,
aber ich weiß nicht, wo sie rumgammelt.
Wahrscheinlich bei mir auf dem Schrank oder so.
Tja, das ist die Frage, was du von deinem Mail-Server überwachen willst.
Willst du deine Message-Queue, willst du deine Mail-Queue überwachen?
Da gibt es dann meistens irgendwelche eingebauten Tools,
um sich die Mail-Queue-Größe anzeigen zu lassen.
Kann das bestimmt auch in irgendeinen Prometheus-Exporter packen oder sowas.
Willst du quasi so Blackbox testen, also willst du quasi Mails verschicken über deinen Mail-Server
und gleichzeitig gucken, ob die ankommen?
Das ist ja dann quasi nicht direktes Monitoring vom Mail-Server, sondern Funktion des Mail-Servers.
Ah ja, Problem ist, dass es meist erst zu spät auffällt, um es zu analysieren.
Tja, also das könntest du tatsächlich machen.
Du könntest dir Mails schicken und gucken, ob die ankommen.
Ansonsten, ich meine, du kannst die üblichen Verdächtigen überwachen auf deinem Mail-Server.
Du kannst das Log, also das Log würde ich auf jeden Fall irgendwo einliefern lassen,
je nachdem, wie viel da durchgeht.
Sei es nur Airsoft-Logging, Wünschreiben.
Also Log-Analyse, dann kannst du die üblichen Verdächtigen von RAM-Usage,
Disk-Usage, CPU-Usage, Prozesse,
Logs, was auch immer machen.
Du kannst deine Mail-Queue-Size überwachen, wie viele Mails in der Mail-Queue sind,
ob sich das irgendwie aufstaut.
Ja, und wenn du den Zeitpunkt nicht richtig mitbekommst,
ganz ehrlich, das Einfachste wäre wahrscheinlich, Mails schicken und gucken, ob die ankommen.
Dann kannst du dir nämlich sicher sein, wenn die ankommen, dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Wenn das halt nur so sporadische Fehler sind,
dass dann so eine Mail von tausend gedroppt wird, ja.
Ha!
Dann habe ich keine Ahnung.
Dann hängt es wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen vom Mail-Server ab.
Dann müsste man sich was anderes überlegen.
Also ich würde tatsächlich Log-Analyse erstmal gucken,
das Ding auf möglichst verbose stellen.
Heißt das eigentlich verbose oder heißt das verbos?
Wie heißt denn das eigentlich?
Ja.
Pronunciation.
Wubo...
Wubovs.
Verbose.
Alles klar.
Weder noch so noch...
Gut.
Wenn Google das sagt, dann muss das stimmen.
Also wir machen das mittlerweile auch so.
Das haben wir sogar im Stream mal programmiert.
So wie das...
Ja, genau.
Also ich habe ja auch im Stream mal was programmiert, was genau dafür da ist.
Also wir machen das auch mittlerweile so.
Also Hintergrund ist, wir sind mal auf einer...
Ne, wir sind nicht auf einer Spam-Liste gelandet.
Das ist falsch.
Weil wenn wir auf einer Spam-Liste gelandet wären,
dann könnte man das auch anderweitig abführen.
Und fragen, ob man auf einer Spam-Liste ist oder nicht.
Wir wurden mal bei United Internet
rate-limited
und dann irgendwann auch temporär geblockt.
Weil irgendwelche Außendienstleute
keine Ahnung, 40.000 Geburtstagsmails verschickt haben oder so.
Musst du dir vorstellen, ne?
War halt einer der Meinung, er muss Geburtstagsmails oder sowas schreiben.
Gut.
Zumindest, das ist halt nicht richtig aufgefallen.
Und daraufhin haben wir gesagt,
wisst ihr, wir machen jetzt den Easy-Mode.
Moin Chris.
Wir machen jetzt den Easy-Mode.
So wie wir es sicher mitbekommen,
ob wir rate-limited oder geblockt sind.
Wir verschicken uns einfach Mails.
Wir verschicken uns selbst Mails.
Wir verschicken aktuell Mail an Gmail,
gmx und web.de
und
über eine Stunde.
Also Default-Einstellungen, so wie ich das gebaut habe,
ist alle 10 Minuten schickt er eine Mail
an diese drei Anbieter.
Und wenn er 10 Mails verschickt hat,
also 10 Minuten nachdem er die zehnte Mail verschickt hat,
guckt er dann per IMAP nach,
ob die alle angekommen sind.
Und wenn Anzahl der verschickten Mails gleich der Anzahl der
Received-Mails auf allen Mail-Accounts ist,
dann ist alles gut.
Ansonsten, ja, muss man sich überlegen,
was man machen will.
Also es gibt noch keine großen Alerts.
Aber was sie dann mit den Prometheus-Metriken machen,
können sie sich ja überlegen.
Aber so machen wir das auch,
weil wir es oft genug jetzt schon nicht mitbekommen haben.
Und das mit dem Spam, mit dem
wir wurden rate-limited,
war jetzt halt letzter Zeit
was so ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen hat.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, wir basteln da mal was.
Löscht er die Mails auch von selbst wieder
oder läuft das IMAP-Post von irgendwann?
Ja, der löscht alle Mails.
Nachdem er seinen Rundlauf einmal durch hat,
und geguckt hat, wie viele Mails angekommen sind,
löscht er auch alle Mails wieder.
Und für den Fall der Fälle,
dass er sogar richtig, richtig Six hat,
für den Fall der Fälle,
dass Mails sehr, sehr langsam in der Zustellung sind,
sodass quasi Mails verloren gehen,
aber dann bei dem Check quasi
die Mails vom vorvorletzten Durchgang erst ankommen,
weil rate-limit,
habe ich in jeder Mail eine Unique-ID stehen,
die nur für diesen Durchlauf gültig ist
und erzählt nur E-Mails, wo die Unique-ID steht.
Aber löschen tut er alle.
Das heißt, es müssen zehn Mails
innerhalb von eineinhalb Stunden angekommen sein
und die müssen alle die passende Unique-ID enthalten.
Und nur dann zählt er die, alle anderen nicht.
Haben wir im Stream irgendwann mal angefangen zu bauen?
Mittlerweile läuft das bei uns,
also läuft das bei mir auf der Arbeit live.
Funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut.
Moin, ich, pepega, habe meinen Firmenantrag
mit Authenticator aus Versehen...
Oh, das ist doof.
Haben die keinen Backup?
Wobei, ich habe auch keinen Backup, Keckel.
Ich habe einen Backup mal gemacht vor...
Also doch, ich habe einen Backup
von vor einem Jahr oder so von meinem iPhone.
Was aber für die Authenticator-App...
Ne, bringt auch nichts.
Ne, bringt dir nichts.
Da wurde wahrscheinlich einiges danach geedit.
Das ist übrigens auch noch was,
was ich im Dezember unbedingt machen muss
und ich weiß immer noch nicht genau, was ich mache.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich kaufen soll.
Also es ist ja ein durchaus realistisches Szenario,
dass ich nächstes Jahr nicht mehr dort arbeite,
wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Und aktuell benutze ich das Firmen-iPhone,
genauso wie Rosario.
Allerdings, wenn ich das Firmen-iPhone...
Also wenn ich kündige dort,
dann kann ich das Firmen-iPhone nicht mehr verwenden.
Dementsprechend brauche ich ein eigenes Smartphone
und ich brauche ein paar Monate Zeit,
weil ich mache ja darüber auch mit einigen Services
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung und Authenticator
und zum Beispiel für Hetzner-Login und so.
Die muss ich alle umziehen
auf mein neues Smartphone.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht innerhalb von 1-2 Wochen machen,
weil ich vergesse garantiert irgendwas,
wo ich mich nicht so oft einlogge.
Das heißt, ich brauche dann schon so 1-2 Monate Zeit,
das umzuziehen.
Das heißt, ich müsste mir eigentlich jetzt mal
ein Smartphone kaufen
und ich tendiere aktuell tatsächlich zum iPhone 14 Pro.
Ich musste gerade überlegen.
Aber iPhone 14 Pro.
Nicht Max.
Sondern das mit 6,1-Toll-Display.
Ist halt teuer as fuck.
1.000 bis 1.200 Euro.
Das wird ein teurer Dezember, sage ich euch, Leute.
4.500 Euro Rechner.
1.200 Euro Smartphone.
Und vor 2 Monaten 25.000 Euro Auto.
Keckel.
Ich brauche mehr Subs, Leute.
Any Primers?
Doch, ich...
Nee, ich kaufe kein iPhone Max.
Auch wenn ich Max heiße.
Nee, nee.
Das ist...
Mir ist das...
Ich habe aktuell ein iPhone...
Was ist denn das?
iPhone 11?
Ich glaube, ich habe aktuell ein iPhone 11.
Das hat ja auch ein 6,1-Toll-Display
oder 6,07-Toll oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber das ist mir schon zu groß.
Also nicht vom Display, sondern vom Daumen her.
Also wenn ich das halte,
wenn ich das Smartphone halte
und möchte beispielsweise die Lampe anmachen
oder auf den...
oder die Kamera aufmachen,
da komme ich mit dem Daumen gar nicht richtig unten hin.
Also das ist gerade...
Also 6,1-Toll ist gerade das,
was ich einhändig mit dem Daumen ordentlich bedienen kann.
Also nicht mal ordentlich,
was ich gerade so noch bedienen kann.
Hegen, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Hat schon funktioniert, ja.
Alles.
Horror-Subscriptions.
Wie man liest, hat anscheinend
Forever Workstation derzeit noch ein Problem mit der Zu...
Ja...
Das werden sie schon auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ich gebe leider keine Antwort.
Ich gebe leider kein iPhone Mini mehr.
Ja, ich finde den 6,1-Toll-Bildschirm,
ehrlich gesagt, gute Kombination.
Ist wirklich groß genug,
dass es dich nicht stört.
Ich gucke da ja auch abends im Bett,
gucke ich da Livestreams drauf,
obwohl ich ein iPad habe.
Reicht mir komplett.
Im Bett hast du das ja eh nicht,
drei Meter wegstehen oder so.
Und größer wäre vielleicht cool,
rein zum Gucken,
aber von der Bedienung her
und für in die Hose stecken,
dann schon wieder doof.
Aber gerade von der Bedienung her.
Brauchst du ja einen neuen Monitor zum Rechner?
Wahrscheinlich nicht gleich.
Wahrscheinlich erst später,
weil ich da noch gucken muss.
Irgendein OLED-Display wird es aber werden.
Das wird teuer, sage ich euch.
Überlegt euch mal.
Neuer Rechner, iPhone, OLED-Display.
Bin ich bestimmt.
6.000, 7.000 Euro noch mal los dieses Jahr.
Muss ich mehr Sellouts machen?
Leute, ich mache noch mal Sellout demnächst.
Hier.
Ähm...
Hier, 16. bis 22. die Woche
mache ich noch mal Sellout.
Für Gaming Equipment aber diesmal.
Was hältst du von den neuen AMD GPUs?
Naja, ist ja noch nicht wirklich
belastbare Benchmarks und sowas raus.
Es gibt so Abschätzungen von ungefähr so 4090.
AMD selbst sagt,
das ist eher,
sehen sie sich als Konkurrenztour 4080,
was wahrscheinlich auch sinnvoller ist,
weil viel mehr Leute sich eine 4080 kaufen werden,
wenn es denn dann eine gibt,
lieferbar,
als eine 4090.
Aber man darf es nicht unterschätzen,
dass es ein gewisses Prestige hat,
die schnellste Grafikkarte zu haben.
Was ist Sellout?
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich Werbung mache bei mir für Genshin Impact
oder äh...
Wie hieß das andere Ding?
Match Masters oder sowas.
Ich mache halt ein, wie nennt man das heutzutage?
Ein Product Placement nennt man das ja.
Ich sage immer Sellout dazu.
Man verkauft, ne?
Sellout ist glaube ich übersetzt,
was heißt denn Sellout übersetzt?
So was wie, man hat sich verkauft oder so?
Wenn jemand ein Sellout ist,
dann hat er sich verkauft.
Oder?
Ausverkau...
Hat sich selbst ausverkauft.
Also, wenn ich Sellout mache,
dann habe ich halt mein...
Ja, genau, sowas.
Habe ich meine Seele für 60 Sekunden verkauft.
Was man, finde ich,
den Product Placements durchaus anhört.
Aber ey, Leute,
ich habe mir das nicht ausgedacht,
dass die Product Placements immer so bescheuert klingen.
Ich habe bei Genshin sowas,
also bei Genshin und bei Matchmasters,
am Anfang selbst einen Vorschlag gemacht
für den Text, ja?
Und beides wollten sie nicht haben.
Beides haben sie gesagt,
nee, nee,
nehmen wir lieber unser offizielles Skript.
Und dementsprechend hört sich das halt auch an.
Oh!
Matchmasters hat noch gar nicht bezahlt, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, ich habe den noch gar nicht gerechnet.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz checken.
Moment, wo ist mein Handy?
Moment.
App.
Banking App.
Aha.
Aber Genshin haben sie bezahlt.
Das ist gut.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Noch nicht.
Klang wie eine Präsentation in der 7. Klasse.
Also ich finde,
da hast du relativ gut präsentiert,
wenn das in der 7. Klasse bei dir schon so klang.
Also wenn ich an die Präsentation denke,
die ich mir da in der Schule anhören musste,
die waren einfach alle nur schlecht.
Meine eingenommen.
Das machen eigentlich die Stonks, Leute.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz Aktien checken.
Stonks diesen Monat plus 396 Euro.
Aber das ist letztendlich egal,
weil dieses Jahr ist minus 1589 Euro und 34 Cent.
Also dieses Jahr waren die Stonks eher Not-Stonks.
Ein gebrauchtes Vorgänger-iPhone?
Nee.
Tja, also dieses Jahr war eher Stonks-Verlust angesagt.
Ja.
Wie viel Prozent sind das?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das steht da gar nicht.
Gibt keine, gibt keine Prozent.
Ah hier, Moment.
Prozent.
Doch.
Nee.
Minus 8,1 Prozent im letzten Jahr.
Minus 8,1 Prozent.
Das geht doch noch.
Ja, das ist auch nur so wenig,
weil es halt ein World-ETF ist
und dementsprechend das
langsam hoch und langsam runter geht.
Aber dieses Jahr ging es halt zum größten Teil
einfach nur runter.
Was aber nicht so schlimm ist,
weil ich habe fast als es am tiefsten Stand war,
vor zwei Wochen ungefähr,
es war im Juni, war es nochmal ein bisschen tiefer,
fast als es auf dem tiefsten Stand war,
habe ich nochmal 8000 Euro nochmal gekauft.
So, ab jetzt kann es wieder hochgehen.
Aber das Dumme ist, wahrscheinlich geht es noch weiter runter.
F.
Ups.
Habe ich jetzt gedrückt.
Hey Max, was geht?
Wie war deine Woche?
Wie war meine Woche?
Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Ich habe eine Bewerbung abgeschickt
und ich habe auch schon eine Antwort gekriegt,
dass es demnächst Einladungen gibt.
Ging wahnsinnig schnell.
Wie gesagt, ich habe Bewerbung hochgeladen,
also Bewerbung per Mail geschickt
und hat irgendwie zwei Tage später die Ansage,
die Antwort schickt.
Aber ich weiß schon, dass jetzt Einladung kommt.
Also aus der Gesichtspunkt ganz gut.
Viele Punkte bei mir auf der Arbeit gehen mir immer noch auf den Keks,
weil halt Homeoffice und gewollte Anwesenheitspflicht und sowas.
Ich habe übrigens gemerkt, wie krass meine Effektivität oder,
nicht effektiv nennt man das,
meine Arbeitsleistung im Endeffekt darunter leidet,
kein Homeoffice mehr zu haben.
Ich habe mal geguckt, was ich diese Woche hingekriegt habe
und es war wirklich fast nichts.
Zu geil.
Dienstag bin ich auf die Arbeit gefahren,
war müde as fuck,
weil ich halt wieder 6.30 Uhr schon
und die Bahn wieder nicht gekommen ist,
unterwegs war.
Ich war gefühlt den halben Tag im Halbschlaf.
Und eigentlich nur mehr oder weniger gemietet,
dienstags ein bisschen.
Mittwochs noch müde gewesen vom Dienstag.
Tatsächlich ein bisschen was gemacht,
aber auch hauptsächlich gemietet.
Mittwochs war der einzige Tag, wo ich wirklich ganz normal
von morgens bis mittags was sinnvolles gemacht habe,
wenn auch nicht durchgängig,
weil du kannst dich schlecht acht Stunden am Stück komplett konzentrieren.
Mittwoch habe ich wirklich,
der einzige Tag, wo wirklich was richtig sinnvolles war,
äh nicht Mittwoch, Schwachsinn,
Donnerstag, Mittwoch nicht.
Donnerstag, der einzige Tag, wo ich wirklich richtig viel gemacht habe,
da war ich wieder fit
und es waren nicht so viele Meetings.
Und Freitag hatte ich Dünnschuss.
Da habe ich auch nichts gemacht.
Also ich habe die Woche nicht sonderlich viel gemacht.
Aber ich habe eine Bewerbung abgeschickt
und Antwort bekommen.
War gespannt.
Wie schätzt du die Entwicklung von Twitter ein?
Ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, da wird ein bisschen zu sehr aktuell
der Weltuntergang prophezeit.
Ich meine, es ist einiges ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Zum Beispiel habe ich gelesen, dass jetzt alle Werbepartner,
die keinen Bock mehr auf Twitter haben,
public geshamed werden sollen.
Da fragt man sich auch, was zum Teufel geht mit dem Kerl ab.
Ich meine, du kannst doch nicht auf der einen Seite sagen,
ja, hier Redefreiheit und alles, was ich gut finde,
muss ich nochmal betonen, was ich gut finde,
aber dann auf der anderen Seite,
wenn sich jemand aus freien Stücken dazu entscheidet,
nicht mehr werben zu wollen,
dann muss man den public shamen oder wie oder was.
Also die Logik habe ich, die verstehe ich nicht so genau.
Also es ist nicht, es ist natürlich nicht,
es ist eigentlich wie immer.
Es ist nicht alles geil und nicht alles schlecht.
Manche Reaktionen finde ich persönlich ziemlich übertrieben.
Zum Beispiel, dass schon bei der puren Ankündigung,
dass hier Elon jetzt ins Twitter-Hauptquartier einmarschiert ist,
die ersten deutschen Politiker gesagt haben,
oh, ich ziehe mich von dieser Plattform zurück.
Warum?
Twitter ist immer nach wie vor eine super Plattform,
um, sagen wir mal, mit dem gemeinen Volk zu kommunizieren.
Wenn auch wahrscheinlich meistens die Leute gar nicht selbst twittern,
sondern irgendwelche Social-Media-Teams, aber trotzdem.
Warum weiß ich davon? Ich bin in Andorra.
Ja, manchmal fliege ich auch kurz rüber.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, wo wollen sie denn sonst hin?
Es gibt doch nichts Vergleichbares zu Twitter für solche Sachen.
Wollen die jetzt, wollen die jetzt zu Instagram?
Ach Quatsch, das ist doch nicht für die Masse.
Kannste knicken.
Twitter hat Geld und gewisse Popularität gehabt
und er hat auch versucht, irgendwas mit seiner eigenen Plattform,
ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie das Ding heißt,
da zu reißen und das, weiß nicht, da ist doch auch keiner wirklich hingegangen.
Truth Social, hieß das so?
Kann ja durchaus sein, dass der bald wieder am Start ist auf Twitter.
Ja, ist auch nicht besser, oder? Ist auch nicht besser.
Also, es gibt ja da keine wirkliche Alternative zu, so.
Die Masse ist auch nicht auf Twitter.
Moment, es geht nicht um die Gesamtheit der Menschheit,
es geht um das, wie es aktuell auf Twitter ist.
Also, es geht ja explizit um Twitter, nicht um die gesamte Menschheit.
Wenn du die gesamte Menschheit anguckst, dann ist die gesamte Menschheit wahrscheinlich kaum irgendwo,
weil die China-Chinesen sind auf WeChat und auf ihrem komischen Panda, nee, wie heißt das?
Ach, keine Ahnung, also das ist ja auch sehr verteilt, ja.
Wie heißt denn ihr Google? Baidu, Baidu, oder? Baidu?
Ist Baidu nicht denn ihr Facebook oder ihr Google, oder wie war das? Baidu.
Das ist die Suchmaschine, ja, das ist das China-Chinesen-Google.
Waibu gibt's auch, ich kenn nur Baidu.
Man kann auch in die Baidu Cloud, wenn man will.
Leute, also falls einer mal in die Baidu Cloud will, gucken wir uns mal an, was die Baidu Cloud kostet.
Cloud Service, Disk. Baidu AI Cloud, Infinite Possibilities.
Ok, zeig her. Highspeed-Seite. Preise.
Das machen sie schon mal wie die Großen. Das machen sie schon mal wie die Großen.
Keine Preise hinschreiben. Keine Preise. Preise sind outdated.
Preise schreibt man bei Cloud nicht hin.
Ah, gutes Times New Roman und kaputte, kaputte Fonts.
Nice. Baidu Cloud.
Ja, aber ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt.
Den Weltuntergang sehe ich da allerdings nicht.
Genauso wenig, so hundertprozentig diese Sache mit blauer Haken soll kostenpflichtig werden und sowas.
So sehr verstehe ich die Aufregung darum ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Es ist halt die Frage, was hinten dran hängt.
Wenn 8 Euro bedeutet, es ist halt in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein Verifizierungsprozess.
Der blaue Haken, der sollte ja eigentlich nur eins bedeuten.
Dass es der echte Account quasi ist.
Also, dass quasi die Person, die man mit dem Account verbindet, auch derjenige ist, zu dem der Account gehört.
So, und ich meine, das kann jeder Hinz und Kunz ja theoretisch sich verifizieren lassen.
Mal davon abgesehen, es interessiert halt keinen.
Und ob das jetzt so der Verkaufsschlager wird, habe ich auch mal meine Zweifel.
Weil ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, ich habe bis heute keinen blauen Haken bei Twitter.
Und juckt mich auch überhaupt nicht, ob ich einen blauen Haken habe bei Twitter oder nicht.
Also, was ich wichtiger finde, ist auf...
Weil auf Twitter siehst du ja wenigstens immer genau, wer was ist und wer was schreibt.
Ja, da gibt es ja auch Namen nur einmal.
Auf YouTube, auf YouTube ist es tatsächlich relativ wichtig, dass man den Verified Haken hat.
Denn auf YouTube kann sich jeder MaxFPS nennen.
Oder jeder, ähm, gibt es noch Kronk oder so nennen.
Und sich sogar das gleiche Bild wie Kronk und Max machen.
Oder wie ApoRed.
Und na gut, ob sich heute noch einer großartig ApoRed faket, weiß man nicht.
Aber könnten alle machen.
Oder InScope oder so.
Also du kannst auf YouTube easy faken.
Und wenn du nicht gerade über den Avatar beziehungsweise den Channel gehst und dann feststellst, das ist aber gar nicht der echte, dann hast du Pech.
Deswegen ist dieser Verified Haken auf YouTube, finde ich, wichtig.
Weil du auf YouTube sehr, sehr einfach Identitäten faken kannst.
Aber auf Twitter, pff, ganz ehrlich, wen juckt's?
Der, der kritische Hase, ja.
Gibt ein neues Keck-Video von ApoRed.
Oh ne, das letzte hat mir schon gereicht.
Das Genshin Impact.
Wobei wir haben ja gar nicht das ApoRed Genshin Impact Video geguckt, sondern dieses, ähm, Meta-Video über sein Genshin Sponsoring.
Wobei ich da immer noch sagen muss, ich weiß nicht, was da alles gelaufen ist.
Aber, dass sein Cutter irgendwelches privates Video-Footage liegt.
Gehört sich eigentlich nicht.
Gut, wer weiß, was daran, was dahinter alles passiert ist.
Vielleicht hat er ihn nicht bezahlt, was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber an sich finde ich das keine gute Aktion.
Ja, Trump schreibt viel, wenn er taglang ist.
Beziehungsweise erzählt viel.
Er hat ja auch erzählt, dass man Desinfektionsmittel zu sich nehmen soll.
Da kann man jetzt nicht so viel drauf geben.
Ja, die jetzt teilweise auch wegrennen.
Und alle Werbepartner, die wegrennen, sollen jetzt ja public geshamed werden, dass sie wegrennen.
Wenn das, ja, warum nicht?
Wie gesagt, ich finde es nicht verkehrt, diesen Verifizierungshaken für alle anzubieten.
Ob das jetzt der Renner wird, habe ich meine Zweifel.
Weiß jemand, wie man Daten auf dem Heap in C++ speichert?
Ja, einfach nicht auf dem Stack speichern.
Just, just do it.
Also, aus meiner Sicht dürfte das relativ einfach sein.
Also, aus meiner, ich kenne mich zwar nicht so mit Speichermanagement von C++ aus.
Aber aus meiner Ansicht dürfte das relativ einfach sein.
Alles, was du nicht lokal in deiner Funktion definierst, ist auf dem Heap.
Und alles, was du lokal in deiner Funktion definierst, ist auf dem Stack.
Also sprich, das, was automatisch aufgeräumt wird danach und dich nicht drum kümmern musst, ist auf dem Stack.
Und der Rest ist auf dem Heap, wo du selbst manuelles Memory, oder manuelles Memory Management, sagen wir mal.
Es geht ja auch sowas wie smarte Pointer und sowas in C++ mittlerweile.
Ja, genau.
Und im Prinzip ist es, ja, wenn du, wenn du new verwendest, wenn du globale, globale Variablen wahrscheinlich, vermute ich mal, keine Ahnung.
Wenn du die globalen Variablen verwendest und new verwendest, ja, so würde ich das sagen.
Also zumindest rate ich das mal so.
Bei C++ weiß man ja nie.
Aber klingt, klingt sinnvoll, ja.
Also alles, was länger lebt als deine Funktion.
Länger lebt als deine Funktion ausgeführt wird, ist auf dem Heap.
Weil ansonsten wird es ja nicht, wird es ja nicht funktionieren.
Du musst ja, sonst wäre es ja weg.
Könntest du mich hochladen?
Geile Kombination aus Name und Text.
Das Breitband-Ausbau-Video möchte hochgeladen werden.
Ja, könnte ich machen, aber ich habe es noch nicht fertig aufgenommen.
Ich finde das übrigens toll, dass du einen Twitch-Name gemacht hast,
der sich wahrscheinlich nur darauf bezieht, dass ich vor drei Monaten gesagt habe,
ich will ein Video hochladen zum Breitband-Ausbau.
High IQ Twitch-Name.
Ja.
Wobei ja die C++-Leute jetzt sagen, nein, du darfst new nicht mehr verwenden.
New ist ganz, ganz böse.
Ich habe zwar immer noch nicht so genau verstanden, warum.
Heutzutage rappen die das lieber in 30 Smart-Pointer, dass die Zeile anstatt so lang, so lang ist.
Aber okay.
C++ versteht eh keiner.
Wann kommt das nächste agile Jobstellen-Angebot-Video?
Da muss ich mal gucken.
Wird echt mal wieder Zeit.
Ich habe letztens wieder ein richtig abschreckungs...
C++-Abschreckungs-Video gesehen.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an.
Ich zeige euch nur mal Best Cases.
Auch das ist was für mich.
Das müssen wir gleich gucken.
Best Cases.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Brauche ich einen Prezi-Case.
C++.
Jason.
Konferenztalk.
C++.
Konf.
Hallo.
C++.
Konf.
Hier.
So.
Das gucken wir nicht.
Keine Sorge.
Ich will euch nur mal ein abschreckendes Beispiel zeigen, was in C++ als toll empfunden wird.
Und sogar in einem offiziellen Konferenztalk vorkommt.
Achtung.
Nur kurz vorspulen.
Das ist alles abartig.
Aber.
Ah.
Zum Beispiel.
Es geht schon los.
So was.
Wobei das insgesamt noch geht.
Das geht noch deutlich schlimmer.
Wo war denn das?
Hier.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Keck, Alter.
Was ist das für eine Syntax schon wieder?
Ne, Moment.
Das ist gar nicht das, was ich...
Naja, doch.
Teilweise.
Teilweise schon.
Guck dir das mal an.
Keck, Alter.
Was ist das für eine Syntax schon wieder?
Ne, Moment.
Das ist gar nicht das, was ich...
Naja, doch.
Teilweise.
Teilweise schon.
Guck dir das mal an.
Was zum...
TemplateTypeName.
TradesType.
UsingSRTDeckelType.
TradesTypeSRT.
Das meinte ich.
Guckt euch das mal an hier.
What the...
What the hell?
Was bin...
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Was...
Was soll...
Was soll das überhaupt sagen?
Was...
Guckt euch das mal an.
Gibt es irgendjemand, der wirklich sich das anguckt und sagt, ach ja, ja, obviös,
was hier passiert?
Was...
Was soll...
Was soll das überhaupt sagen?
Ok.
Also ich weiß nicht.
Das einzige was ich checke ist, dass es eine constexpr ist.
Das bedeutet, das ist compiltime.
So.
Aber jetzt ist vorbei.
Standard эксперimental is detected op TradesType doppel doppel Punkt Value Reまり-
Leute...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber anscheinend löst man damit irgendwelche jason Probleme.
Und wisst ihr ja was?
Witz ist, soll ich euch mal
einen Witz an C++ erzählen, an der Standard
Library? Die Standard Library von
C++ hat im Jahr 2022
keinen JSON
Parser und, jetzt haltet
euch mal fest, keinen
HTTP Client. Ich glaube
Socket, ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, ob
Sockets Teil der Standard Library
sind. Ne, ich glaube nicht, oder?
Also die C++ Standard Library
hat keinerlei Networking.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Für eine
Programmiersprache, die jetzt in Version
2023 rauskommt.
Ja, wer, wer, ich mein,
wer braucht heutzutage schon HTTP
und JSON Serializing und Deserializing?
Ist ja komplett, komplett
overrated.
Ja, und wenn jetzt irgendjemand sagt,
ähm,
braucht man nicht, Sockets kommen aus
dem Betriebssystem her dann. Ja, das ist ja schön und gut,
wenn die aus dem Betriebssystem her dann kommen.
Aber warum gibt es keine einheitliche,
sei es nur irgendein Rapper,
in der Standard Library, dass man es eben überall
ordentlich, gleichermaßen verwenden kann.
Und wer jetzt, wenn
jetzt einer sagt, ja, aber es liegt doch
daran, dass C++ überall lauffähig
sein muss,
also auch, äh, auf Microcontroller
und sonst was, naja,
du kannst ja ohne Probleme
auch Funktionen
def, also man kann es ja auch
in die Standard Library, sagen wir mal, einen HTTP Client
packen und wenn deine Plattform
aus welchen Gründen auch
immer keine Netzwerkkommunikation,
erlaubt,
dann ist es da halt nicht implementiert,
beziehungsweise es gibt eine Exception oder
es gibt, äh, was auch immer, irgendwas
definiertes, ja. Aber
nachdem so ziemlich jede Plattform,
außer vielleicht jetzt irgendwelche Microcontroller
für Industriesteuerung, irgendwas mit
Netzwerk am Hut haben, ja.
Also Python in der Standard Library kannst du
ohne Probleme ein, äh, ein, ein, ein HTTP
Request machen.
Wie du ein HTTP Request in C++
machst,
du musst dir
eine der tausend,
C++ HTTP Libraries raussuchen.
Wahrscheinlich hast du Glück
und deine jeweilige Plattform,
zum Beispiel, wenn du für ein ESP32
machst, hat schon
einen eingebauten HTTP Client.
Der ESP, also die, die
ESP32, ähm,
Hersteller Library bringt das, bringt das schon mit.
Leider, leider nur komplett
in C oder Arduino hat, Arduino?
Hat Arduino einen, einen Web Client
standardmäßig? Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ja, in C, ja, in C,
in C ist klar, dass, also das ist in C,
in C nicht, ach, in C++.
Lip Curl.
Ah.
Lip Curl, warum, wie gesagt, warum ist sowas
nicht in der Standard, Standard Library drin?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Schon mal was von Code Interview, du meinst,
ob du den Binary Tree inverten kannst?
Ähm, ob, ob ich schon mal ein
Code Interview machen musste?
Nö. Ich musste aber eh kaum,
kaum Interviews machen, weil
ich musste ein Vorstellungsgespräch
machen
an meiner Ausbildung.
Da ging's nicht
um irgendwelche Programmiersachen, da ging's halt
um was, was ich, äh, was,
was war denn das? Ähm, mein DSL-Anschluss,
was ich damit schon gebastelt hab und so Dinger.
Was war denn für die Ausbildung?
So, dann haben die mich übernommen nach der
Ausbildung, da musste ich kein Vorstellungsgespräch
mal führen. Dann bin ich
gewechselt zur Bank nach
Frankfurt, wo ich jetzt arbeite. Da musste
ich auch kein richtiges Vorstellungsgespräch mehr
führen, weil ich die Leute schon kannte.
Das, das, also
das Einzige, wo ich
Gespräche geführt hab, tatsächlich, ist noch
nicht lange her. Einmal
bei dem
letzten Laden, wo's leider nix geworden ist,
Corona-bedingt, hab ich ein,
das war nicht wirklich ein, kein richtiges
Interview, das war so ein halbes, war nur ein halbes
Vorstellungsgespräch.
Ähm, da ging's aber auch
nicht darum, programmier mal was. Und jetzt,
irgendwann nächste Woche oder so,
oder wann auch immer das genau ist,
aber ich denke auch nicht, dass ich da irgendwas programmieren muss.
Mal schauen. Weiß ich nicht, hab ich noch nicht gemacht.
Aber im Zweifelsfall kann
ich den Binary Tree inverten. Das ist gut.
Das Einzige, was ich kann.
Binary Trees inverten.
Ja, da kann man sich, da kann
man sich jetzt tatsächlich drüber streiten.
Es gibt ja, gibt
ja unterschiedliche Ansätze, aber
ich find's gut, wenn die Standard
Library umfangreich ist.
Einfach, weil's da nicht diese Frage
gibt, weil's da nicht die JavaScript-Problematik
gibt. IsOdd und
isEven als Package und
in 250 Projekten als, äh,
250.000 Projekten als Abhängigkeit.
Und, ähm, weil's halt
einen Weg gibt, wie's
zu, sagen wir mal, 90% gemacht
wird, wenn das Standard-Library-Zeug ausreicht.
In Rust ist es auch so,
die Rust-Standard-Library
hat teilweise coole Sachen, ja,
die haben eine Channel-Implementierung, die haben
ähm,
UTF-8-String-Support, der richtig gut ist,
im Vergleich zu anderen Sprachen, wenn man sich
zum Beispiel mal C++ anguckt.
Oder auch .NET. Gut, der
UTF-8-Support in .NET ist jetzt wirklich netz oder Wahnsinn.
Ähm, aber vieles hat Rust in der Geschichte.
Und in der Standard-Library auch nicht.
Also ich glaube, du kannst in der Standard-Library von Rust
auch kein HTTP-Request machen, oder?
Ne, kannst du auch nicht machen.
Also Rust ist auch sehr minimalistisch.
Wobei Rust halt auch eine Sprache ist,
die explizit sagt,
sie sind,
also sie
wollen auch lauffähig sein ohne ihre
Standard-Library. Du kannst ja Rust auch
ohne Rust-Standard-Library
kompilieren, wenn du halt nur Sachen verwendest,
die anderweitig da sind.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, finde ich auch kein großer
Fehler. Ich mag das, wenn Standard-Library
technisch alles enthält, was man so
sag mal, zum größten. Ich verwende in .NET
auch viele externen Libraries, ja?
Für irgendwelche Units
zu konvertieren. Ich verwende übrigens auch immer noch
gerne JSON.NET anstatt den
Standard-JSON-Parser in .NET. Also ist da auch nicht
alles rosig.
Aber
zumindest ist ein HTTP-Client drin.
Und noch nicht mal den verwende ich hauptsächlich.
Verwende ich auch einen Wrapper für den
HTTP-Client.
Aber zumindest
ist vieles in der .NET-Standard-Library
drinne und man braucht keine extra Libraries.
Und was musst du
eigentlich hierfür machen?
Libcurl muss ja dann
installiert sein auf dem System.
Oder du musst das irgendwie statisch
kompilieren und so ein Zeug.
Da ist schon wieder irgendwelche Dependencies
drinne.
So blöd's klingt,
und eines der größten Vorteile früher unter
Linux war, so nach dem Motto,
dass du einen ordentlichen Package-Manager hast,
ich persönlich bin mittlerweile
ein richtig großer Fan von
Self-Contained-Applications.
Bisschen wie das Go macht.
Nur dass ich Go als Sprache nicht
übermäßig geil finde.
Aber ich finde das gut, wenn du
ein Binary hast oder ein Folder,
wo alles drin ist, was
du brauchst. Du startest das einfach
und es läuft rückwirkend bis
Linux 2.32
kernel oder so.
.NET hat ein paar Probleme
bei ganz alten Linux-Distros.
Ich glaube .NET ist rückwirkend
lauffähig bis so ungefähr
Ubuntu 14.04 oder so was.
Oder 12.04.
Irgendwie 10 Jahre alt.
Das dürfte in Ordnung sein.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
C++ hat schon auch,
wenn nicht viele, aber hat durchaus auch
paar coole Sachen.
Also, ich flame
ja oft über
C++, aber soll ich euch mal ein paar Sachen
sagen, die ich tatsächlich gut finde an C++?
Eine Sache, die ich gut
finde an C++ ist,
aber das liegt hauptsächlich daran, weil es einfach
absoluter Bullshit war früher, ist
die neue String-Formatting-Library,
die allerdings noch kaum
einen Compiler implementiert.
Das heißt, man muss eigentlich immer noch
die Library von GitHub
importieren, anstatt
einfach das aus der Standard-Library zu verwenden.
Aber dass sie überhaupt eine ordentliche String-Formatting-Library
mittlerweile in der Standard-Lib haben,
finde ich schon mal gut.
Die ist zwar
naja, ganz
okay, sehr stark von der
Python-String-Library, also hier
C++-Fmt.
Dieses Ding ist mittlerweile in der
Standard-Library.
fmtlib.
C++ 20.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es kaum einen Compiler
irgendwie großartig
implementiert, ja.
Also du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel
sowas machen in C++, guck mal.
So
Art, so Art String Interpolation.
So Art,
ja.
Guck mal, sowas, ja.
Also zum ersten Mal, dass man nicht mehr
cout oder printf
oder so ein Rotz machen muss,
vom letzten Jahrtausend, sondern wirklich ordentlich
mal sein Zeug formatieren
kann.
Sogar mit Colors und sowas.
Wobei ich glaube, Colors sind
nicht in der Standard-Library.
Also das ist eine Sache, die finde ich tatsächlich
ganz gut. Ne, eine Sache, die ich
tatsächlich gut an C++ finde, die ich gut
und schlecht an C++ finde, sind Templates.
Templates an sich,
Ausgeburt der Hölle.
Es wird viel zu viel
Template-Magic gemacht.
TypeScript ist übrigens auf einem ähnlichen Weg.
Ich hab letztens gesehen, irgendeiner
hat eine Regex-Engine,
eine Regex-Engine
rein in TypeScript-Types
programmiert. Eine rudimentäre
Regex-Engine
rein in TypeScript-Type-Definitions.
Frag mir nicht, wie das geht.
Gab's letztens irgendwas auf
C++.
Also ganz wirres Zeug.
Zumindest Templates haben eine coole Sache,
die ich wirklich
nice finde, was
mir so in vielen anderen Sprachen,
also was ich nicht aus vielen anderen Sprachen kenne.
Zum Beispiel kannst du in
Templates,
oder nicht nur in Templates, stimmt gar nicht.
Ist Blödsinn. Hat ja gar nichts mit Templates zu tun.
Compile-Time-Expressions.
Das finde ich in C++ tatsächlich ganz nice.
Also mir fällt keine andere Sprache
so spontan ein,
was du als Beispiel sagen kannst.
Das ist eine Funktion,
die akzeptiert ein
Character-Array, also ein String.
Allerdings möchte ich
zur Compile-Zeit checken,
dass niemand, der die Funktion aufruft,
mehr als ein String
übergibt, der länger als 15 Zeichen ist.
Das geht mit
Compile-Time-Expressions in C++.
Das geht natürlich auch nur, solange du nicht
irgendwie dynamisch da was dispatchst und aufrufst
zur Runtime.
Das muss alles zur Compile-Zeit vorliegen.
Aber das kannst du in C++ machen.
Du kannst zum Beispiel in C++ checken,
dass du keine
Strings länger als
15 Zeichen übergibst
an der Funktion.
Das finde ich ganz nice.
Compile-Time-Expressions ist was cooles
in C++.
Sieht zwar im Endeffekt abartig aus,
aber von der Idee her finde ich es nice
und mir fällt auch keine andere Sprache ein,
die das in dem Umfang kann.
Also es ist nicht alles schlecht an C++.
Aber fast alles.
Ich habe schon immer gern programmiert.
Schon auch lange vor meiner Ausbildung.
Schon immer gerne gemacht.
Also das erste,
eines der allerersten Sachen,
die ich je programmiert habe,
war ein...
ein Cheating-Tool war es nicht wirklich
für das MMO.
Ein Tool für das MMO,
was ich damals gespielt habe.
Wobei ich kann es euch erzählen.
Das ist ja nichts
Schlimmes.
Ich habe damals Dark Age of Camelot gespielt.
Bestes MMO aller Zeiten, immer noch.
Und der Hersteller
kam damals auf die Idee,
dass es böse ist, dass man das Spiel
alt-tabben kann.
Überlegt euch mal.
Es gab eine Zeit, da haben die
alt-tab ausgeschaltet, damit man keine Cheats
im Hintergrund laufen lassen kann.
So.
Ich wollte aber im Hintergrund
zumindest mal Musik starten stoppen
und sowas.
Also was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe ein Chatlogger-Tool programmiert.
Man konnte nämlich Chatlog einschalten
und das Spiel hat dann
den Chat quasi protokolliert
in der Datei.
Und ich habe die Datei einfach eingelesen
in regelmäßigen Abständen.
Und habe geschaut, ob ich
irgendwas im Chat geschrieben habe.
Also das heißt, ich konnte dann zum Beispiel
ingame schreiben, so was weiß ich
Player Next oder sowas.
Ja.
Wenn ich das ingame geschrieben habe,
hat
nach ein paar Sekunden das mein Programm
im Chatlog erkannt
und konnte dann die Musik einschalten.
Und konnte dann quasi den Tastendruck simulieren
für Musik weiter und sowas.
Also es war was relativ simples,
rudimentäres.
Aber das war der Grund
damals, warum ich mich angefangen
habe mit Programmieren zu beschäftigen.
Ich habe davor schon ein bisschen rumgewurstet.
Ja.
Aber das ist lange her.
Es kam 2001 oder so raus.
Irgendwie 2002.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es da Autohotkey überhaupt schon gegeben hat.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, Autohotkey
weiß ich nicht, ob das damals
Logdateien überwachen konnte und sonst was.
Aber es war irgendwie 2002 rum.
Das war der Hauptgrund, warum ich angefangen habe
mich mit Programmieren zu beschäftigen.
Weil ich abgefuckt war,
dass sie mir verboten haben Alt-Tab
zu machen im Game.
Bisschen später habe ich dann eine Software gefunden,
wo du jede Fullscreen-Anwendung in Windows packen konntest
und das Spiel auch so dann
in Window-Mode lief.
Aber das war das erste.
Das war das erste, warum ich mich ein bisschen mit Programmieren beschäftigt habe.
Und von da habe ich eigentlich festgestellt,
ist doch ganz nice und macht Bock.
Ja. Das predated noch
Autohotkey.
Das waren auch die Zeiten, wenn man Videos gecaptu...
Wisst ihr, mit was man damals Videos gecaptuert hat,
Leute? So ziemlich der einzige
Video-Capturer, den es damals gab
und der wirklich übelster
Müll gewesen ist?
FRAPS! Richtig!
Aber nicht Hypercam. FRAPS!
FRAPS!
Gab es damals. Du konntest entweder FRAPS
Capturen in Full...
Full-Size vom Display,
was kein Rechner in der Welt damals
handeln konnte, auch I.O. von der Festplatte
und so nicht. Oder Half-Size
und es sah kacke aus.
Ich verstehe bis heute nicht, warum FRAPS nicht
einfach eine normale Auflösung
irgendwie geboten hat.
Danach gab es ein paar andere Tools,
aber FRAPS, ja.
Ich habe damals ein paar Dark-Videos
gemacht mit FRAPS.
Gibt es immer noch
auf YouTube, aber
zeige ich euch jetzt nicht,
weil
man das irgendwie
mit mir persönlich dann in Verbindung bringen könnte.
Ja, weil dann findet man
nämlich zum Beispiel, also
wenn man meinen Username kennt
aus dem Video,
dann findet man meinen
Ingame-Character.
Und dann
findet man wahrscheinlich auch noch eine
Bilder-Seite, wo damals
die Leute
Real-Life-Fotos
geshared haben. Also quasi,
es war quasi ein,
nennen wir es mal, Tinder für MMOs.
Übertrieben.
Übertrieben gesagt. Da konntest du damals
deine Real-Life-Bilder sharen und verbinden
mit deinem Ingame-Character, dass du wusstest,
wer so dahinter steht.
Gachi-Buzz-Videos. Nein, nicht wirklich.
FRAPS
aktuelle Version.
FRAPS, also wer es nicht
kennt. Ja, FRAPS.
Jawoll!
FRAPS-Testversion.
FRAPS.
Wie es einfach mal das erste
Far Cry ist, was die capturen.
By the way, das erste Far Cry sah
wirklich damals absolut
bombastisch aus.
FRAPS-Review.
Das geht mit euch ab.
How to use FRAPS. Ich glaube, FRAPS ist
eines der einfachsten Software überhaupt gewesen.
Warum man dafür eine Anleitung
braucht, ich weiß es nicht.
Guck, das waren die einzigen Display-Settings,
die man... Dexterity
gab es da noch. Ja, da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern.
Du konntest
nur Full-Size oder Half-Size von deiner
Bildschirm-Auflösung aufnehmen.
Das heißt, wenn du Capturen wolltest,
sodass dein Rechner
das schafft, musstest du
runterstellen auf 800x600 oder so.
Weil, ganz
ehrlich,
30 FPS Full-Size.
Full-Size war damals sowas wie
was hat man gespielt?
1600x900 oder sowas.
Oder
was war hier?
Was gab es denn für
4 zu 3 Auflösungen, die beliebt waren?
Ja, hier.
1280x960 oder 1440x1000.
Ne. Ja, doch das oder das.
Genau.
1600x1200 war es.
Und das
konntest du halt im Leben nicht capturen.
Mit FRAPS.
Und selbst Half-Size sah halt
Kacke aus.
Deswegen musstest du dann runterstellen auf 1024.
Es war, Leute, die Zeit war echt nicht schön.
Ganz ehrlich.
Richtig abartig.
Ne, 4 zu 3 Auflösung, nicht 16 zu 9.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal ein bisschen Videos.
Genug
geschwätzt.
In was ist FRAPS gebrogert?
Ich hätte jetzt instinktiv gesagt, wahrscheinlich C.
Aber es könnte auch Pascal
oder sowas gewesen sein.
FRAPS Programming
Language.
Written in Rust.
Placing the fast FRAPS.
Ne, damals hat noch keiner an Rust gedacht.
DirectX OpenGL
Sources.
Ja, weiß man in welcher
Programmiersprache?
Weiß man in was FRAPS programmiert wurde?
Ist OBS better? Ja.
Gab es damals schon Hardware Encoder Unterstützung?
Nö. Gab es nicht. War alles Software.
War alles CPU.
Allerdings muss man sagen,
FRAPS hat es relativ clever gemacht.
Wisst ihr, wie FRAPS
das mit dem Encoding gemacht hat?
Wisst ihr?
Ne, ne, ne.
Das war nicht das Problem.
Wisst ihr, wie FRAPS das mit dem Encoding gemacht hat?
Warum FRAPS überhaupt in der Lage war,
damals Videos in Full-Size
und
30 FPS zu capturen?
Genau, es hat nämlich einfach so gut
wie gar kein Encoding gemacht.
Warum?
Das hat fast mehr oder weniger
RAW die Bilder gespeichert.
Und dementsprechend war das
Encoding kein Problem, aber die Festplatte
konnte das halt nicht.
Du musst, du hattest damals
ratzfatz gigabyteweise FRAPS Aufnahmen.
Und das konnte halt damals keine Festplatte
handeln.
Deswegen musstest du,
eigentlich Half-Size recorden,
was dann wieder kacke aussah. Oder du hast auf einer kleinen
Auflösung gespielt, wo du dann wieder nicht richtig spielst.
Also, das war wirklich,
glaub mir, was Game Capture angeht,
keine gute Zeit.
Ein Kollege von mir damals, mit dem ich zusammen
täglich MMO gecrindet habe,
äh, MMO gecrindet habe,
der hat damals für die
Bravo Screen Fun gearbeitet.
Kennt das irgendwie noch jemand?
Bravo Screen Fun?
Das gab's mal, das war sowas wie die Games,
da nur von Bravo.
Ballermänner, hinein ins Abenteuer, alles klar.
Bravo Screen Fun.
Und der hatte damals
ein Tape Capture
Device. Also, das war
ein Video Capturing
Device, quasi so das Elgato
von 2003.
Das war so ein Teil,
das hast du angeschlossen an PC
und das hat dann aufgenommen in
so einer ganz scheppen Auflösung.
In PAL Auflösung. Was für eine Auflösung hat PAL?
720, genau.
720 mal
576 hat das aufgenommen.
Das war mit Bändern drinne.
Das war ein Recorder mit Bändern.
Und dann, also du konntest das,
du konntest dann quasi aufnehmen ohne
Performance einbußen
am PC. Das hat er damals von der Arbeit
mitgebracht, weil die mussten halt damals für die Screen Fun
auch Videos Capturen und sowas.
Und das hat er mitgenommen,
dass wir ein bisschen PvP Videos
aufnehmen konnten. Und er hat halt gespielt
in, was weiß ich,
wahrscheinlich so wie ich, irgendwie 1600
mal 1200.
Und der hat das halt in PAL
Auflösung gecaptured, dieses Device.
Vom PC fragt mich nicht, wie es genau funktioniert hat.
Und das sah halt schwammig as fuck
aus danach. Aber du konntest halt
ohne, du konntest halt ohne
Performance einbußen capturen.
War halt, war halt richtig geil, ja.
Und danach musstest du, also du musstest erst mal
das aufnehmen auf Tape.
Und dann musstest du es von Tape zum Video schneiden
natürlich wieder auf die Festplatte zurückspielen.
Das war ein Akt von, von Tagen.
Bis das so funktioniert hat.
Aber du konntest halt ohne einbußen capturen.
War halt schon für die damalige Zeit sehr cool.
Ja und rückwirkend aufnehmen
war natürlich auch nicht damals.
Tja.
Das waren wilde, wilde Zeiten.
Mit
Dextory war es dann besser.
Das habe ich, das habe ich auch noch.
Relativ
intensiv verwendet dann.
Weiß nicht, ob es das immer noch gibt.
2007 letzte Version.
Dextory.
Die Webseite geht noch nicht mal mehr.
Warte mal, was ist das? Black Ops 3?
Oder was bin ich hier sehend?
Leute, was ist das?
Black Ops 3?
Black Ops 2?
Wie das ausgeschaut hat.
Leute, wir können
wirklich froh sein, dass OBS
am Start ist. Ich habe
damals, als ich
mit meiner Black Magic Karte
die Xbox gecaptured habe.
Ich habe damals eine eigene Capture
Software, also eine minimal Capture
Software programmiert, die über
Direct Show war das glaube ich.
Über Direct Show von der, von der
Black Magic die Videos abgegriffen
hat und lossless encoded hat.
Aus dem Grund, weil die Black Magic
Karte damals mega nice war,
aber die Aufnahmesoftware nicht gut.
Das war nicht lang, das waren irgendwie 100
Zeilen oder so. Es war wirklich super
rudimentär. Also
da können wir wirklich froh sein, dass wir heute
OBS haben. Und ich meine, es ist ja
nicht nur Elgato. Elgato ist zwar das bekannteste,
aber halt auch ordentliche Capture
Hardware haben auch, auch
teilweise wirklich
da wo du vor ein paar Jahren noch tausende
dafür bezahlt hast, mit
120 Herz Support und allem möglichen.
Also muss man,
muss man echt sagen, da können wir,
da sind wir wirklich blessed
mittlerweile, was das angeht.
Das funktioniert heute einfach.
Pregel, ja. Und
OBS, wer das nicht weiß, die meisten hier
wissen es wahrscheinlich. OBS ist komplett
Open Source Software, die man sich angucken
kann
auf Github.
Es ist eine, es ist
CUTE, CUTE und
es ist C++,
ich glaube es ist eine C++
CUTE Software, wenn ich mich
nicht ganz täusche.
Glaube ich. Ja, ja, ja, ist es.
Ja.
Also OBS Studio ist auch
ein riesen Ding. Streamlabs
OBS, was ist denn daraus eigentlich
geworden?
Die haben sich ja nicht mehr OBS genannt,
die nennen sich jetzt einfach Streamlabs.
Warum sollte ich Streamlabs vs.
OBS verwenden? Sehe ich nicht.
Ich verwende
das Original OBS.
Beste.
Original OBS.
Ach ja.
So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt mal an?
Battlefield Campaign.
Oh ne, please, please.
Die waren alle nicht gut.
Die beste Battlefield-Kampagne war Bad Company 1.
Das konntest du
eigentlich vergessen.
BF3, finde ich, ging auch noch,
wenn man nicht gerade irgendwie ein bisschen außerhalb
gelaufen ist.
Okay, komm, wir lassen uns, wir skippen.
Wir skippen. Wir lassen uns ne Runde Level-Captcha
baiten.
Lass uns ne Runde Level-Captcha baiten.
Credo, dankeschön für den Sub.
Hast du Protato schon gesehen?
Ist das ein Browser?
Oder was ist das? Ne.
Protato.
Gunray, dankeschön für den Sub.
Das sieht vom Artstyle übelst
nach, wisst ihr was mich zu sehen ist?
Also die Monster sehen übelst nach Binding
of Isaac aus.
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Ist das vielleicht sogar vom gleichen Hersteller?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ne, ist es nicht.
Vom Artstyle
her, yes.
Ne, sagt mir nix.
Okay, lasst uns mal Level-Captcha
baiten.
Ja, bringt nix.
Die können noch
so viel machen, dass es der Zug ist abgefahrener.
Man hat auch schon viele Far Cry Spiele entwickelt,
also wird es interessant, was sie in der Battlefield-Franchise bringen können.
In Battlefield Mobile News
wurde das Google Play Store Listing
drei Mal in der letzten Woche
verbessert, mit manchen User
auf den Client zu loggen.
Das ist das Clip,
das sie eins zu eins von World of Tanks
geklaut haben? Oder wie war das?
War das nicht? Oder war das
World of Warships?
Also, es ist schon
sehr auffällig, oder?
Wie ähnlich sich die Spots sind.
Moment, Moment.
Zeigt mal her.
Ui.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was aktuell
relativ viele Spieler hat? Ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
New World.
Guckt mal hier.
Also, für
New World Verhältnisse viele.
123.000.
Aber das liegt nicht daran, dass
das Game jetzt irgendwie super,
super krass ganz neu ist, sondern
es gab wohl einen relativ großen neuen Content
Patch und es gab neue Server,
wo die Leute wieder von Anfang an starten können.
Und
frische Server sind quasi immer
eine gute Möglichkeit
für MMO-Spieler wieder zurückzukriegen.
Overwatch 2.
Nee, Overwatch 2 ist nicht on Steam.
Kannst du nicht gucken.
Oh, Star Citizen geht mir
sonst wo vorbei.
Wollen die nicht vielleicht mal irgendwie
das Game wieder aufbauen?
Ja, das kann man.
Das kann man.
Wir müssen das Game fertig machen, anstatt 30.000
neue Systeme einzubauen.
Okay, fertig ist bei dem Game eh
ein dehnbarer Begriff, ja.
Ja.
Zeit aus dem Dreizig-Werder-Modus.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich habe es jetzt die letzten Tage wieder ein bisschen gespielt
und das Einzige, was ich wirklich in dem Game spielen kann, ohne durchzudrehen, ist Search
and Destroy.
Den Rest halte ich nicht aus.
Was, Moment, das habe ich nicht verstanden, nochmal.
Was, in Ranked soll es, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
In Ranked gibt es weniger SBMM jetzt?
Hä, sollte Ranked nicht der Sinn von SBMM sein und Public eben ohne SBMM?
Oder ich habe es bestimmt falsch verstanden, aber man weiß da ja nie.
SBMM nur in Ranked, das glaube ich nicht.
Die werden SBMM nicht abschaffen aus Quickplay.
Die werden es im Leben nicht rausnehmen, null.
Die anderen Games haben auch SBMM.
Und es hat einen Leak und Ranked Play.
Dieser große Titel wird Respawns zukünftiger Star Wars Jedi Survivor sein,
der hoch erwartete Sequel zu 2019's Fallen Order.
Interessant ist, EA hat erwähnt, wie ihre Marketing-Taktiken in der Zukunft verändern würden.
Statt über ein paar Monate Aufmerksamkeit zu bauen,
werden sie nur ihre Spiele im Launch-Window markieren.
Sie glauben, dass sie das tun, weil Apex Legends so gut war,
als es vor 48 Stunden vor dem Launchen eröffnet wurde.
Dieser Methodus von schockierenden Spielern,
mit einem Überraschungs-Entschluss und dem Launching des Spiels,
scheint sofort positiv auf Spieler-Nummern zu beeinflussen.
Das könnte erklären, warum die Marketing-Taktik noch nicht angefangen hat,
für die Spiele in den Launch-Window zu starten.
Das kann ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, weil dann ist der Hype am größten
und die Leute können gleich ausprobieren.
... die Star Wars-Sequel.
EA wird vielleicht bis zum March-Launch-Window ankommen.
Industrie-Insider Jeff Grubb hat vorhin gesagt,
dass Survivor in den March-Launch-Window starten würde.
Nur dass mich halt, ehrlich gesagt, Star Wars nicht wirklich juckt, aber okay.
... Star Wars nicht wirklich juckt, aber okay.
Ich glaube, das letzte Star-Wars-Singleplayer soll gar nicht übel gewesen sein.
Taugt das? Spielt das jemand von euch?
... Taugt das? Spielt das jemand von euch?
Ich hab das mal gekauft vor zwei Jahren und habe nie gespielt.
... foodceptions, open-field- entrepreneurship,
und neue Auf equivalente書idefaktoren.
Ein exklettes Er tert-decken Stück im Winter...
Chat sagt, Fynn super!
... Ach hat es después von in einer Woche über dem Spiel themselves.
In anderen EA-Inmail-Sachen sind die Amateurs guardước-Felden
beobachte shadow- rectified-am怪ien aufhand teams zu handeln.
Zum Mitbeit각 der Marvel war, dass drei neue Faktoren...
Oh, Residenz-Sleeper-Marvel-Zeug.
Oh, Residenz-Sleeper.
Who cares?
In August, Embracer Group,
the Swedish gaming conglomerate,
bought Square Enix Studio for $300 million.
This included studios like Crystal Dynamics,
Das ist ja...
Soll das irgendein 2D-Tomb Raider sein, oder?
Emix, Eidos Montreal and Square Enix Montreal
combined these studios have published hits like
Deus Ex, Thief and Tomb Raider.
Just two months after this acquisition,
Embracer Group is shutting down
Square Enix.
This studio had just rebranded itself to Anima,
focusing on mobile gaming.
Ah, das ist ein Mobile-Game, verstehe.
Ah, ja dann ist klar.
Na dann ist klar, Mobile-Game.
Na logisch.
Da läuft's bei denen.
Ich mein, hey, wenigstens disablen die Heroes
und nicht so wie beispielsweise,
dass es einen Unverwundbarkeits-Glitch in MW2 gibt,
aber keiner disabelt das Schild.
Und vielleicht ist es mittlerweile gepatcht,
aber es hat ewig gedauert, Wender.
According to a tweet sent out by Blizzard,
a bug with Mei's Ice Wall ability
allowed her to reach unintended locations on the map.
This gave the hero an unfair advantage over others.
Some players see this as another skill to master
when playing as Mei,
but it looks as if Blizzard disagrees.
There's no ETA for when the hero will be added to the game.
This is yet another issue that has plagued
the launch of Overwatch 2,
but hopefully things will be resolved
sooner rather than later.
Xbox-Boss Phil Spencer has once again assured gamers
that Microsoft will keep the Call of Duty-Franchise
on Xbox and PlayStation consoles.
Ja, das habe ich auch gelesen.
Ist aber auch logisch.
Das sage ich auch schon die ganze Zeit.
Es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn,
für die Call of Duty wirklich exklusiv für die Xbox zu machen.
Das würde ja nur Sinn machen,
wenn...
die Verkäufe,
was es an Geld zu holen gibt auf der PlayStation,
in irgendeiner Art und Weise quasi
auf der anderen Seite das übertreffen könnten.
Also sprich, könntest du mit einer Exklusivität
dir in irgendeiner Art und Weise Vorteile verschaffen
oder mehr Geld verschaffen,
die das aufwiegen,
die Verkäufe, die du auf der PlayStation verlierst.
Und das kann ich mir halt nicht vorstellen.
Das sind Millionen, was die machen an Geld,
die sich mit PlayStation verkaufen.
Das müssten die anderen weitlich erstmal reinbekommen.
Also...
Und selbst wenn sie es nicht direkt reinbekommen,
sondern quasi dadurch andere Services pushen können,
dass sich das unterm Strich lohnt,
kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
... Console to ship on,
COD would ship on it.
This topic has been at the very center
of the Microsoft acquisition discussion for months.
Sony is understandably concerned
that COD may become platform-exclusive,
which would impact their sales.
As it stands, Microsoft will ship COD
on PlayStation for several more years
at the very least,
but things still need to be clarified
on what that means exactly.
It is interesting, however,
that Sony is fighting hard to retain non-exclusivity
despite having so many exclusive deals with COD.
Modern Warfare 2 on PlayStation, for example,
awards players with extra tier skips
for the Battle Pass,
an exclusive operator
and additional loadout slots.
Remedy announced this week
that their next major game launch
is still on schedule for next year.
Alan Wake 2 is the long-awaited sequel
to the cult classic
Langfristig auf jeden Fall Geld.
which we're told is still in active development
but progressing well.
Remedy is also working on Codename Condor,
which is a spin-off of 2019's Control.
Control blew fans away
with its incredible graphics
and a mind-bending storyline.
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich bin riesen Fan von Remedy Games.
Also ich hab auch alle,
was heißt ich, ich hab alle gespielt.
Remedy hat nicht viele Games gemacht,
die haben Max Payne 1 gemacht,
Max Payne 2 gemacht,
Alan Wake gemacht,
ähm, wie heißt das andere,
dieses Time Travel Ding,
Quantum Break gemacht,
was haben die sonst noch gemacht?
War's das nicht schon?
Die haben nicht viele Games gemacht.
Und jetzt halt Control.
Und ich muss sagen,
Control war das erste Game,
was ich nicht gespielt habe.
...is the devs answer to that.
However, it's still in a proof-of-concept stage
and a long ways off from release.
Though according to the devs,
the prototype gameplay
already feels very fun.
Another Control game
is also in the works at Remedy.
Code name Heron is suspected to be a direct sequel
to the first game
and continues the main storyline.
AMD has just announced their new graphics cards.
The Radeon RX 7900 XTX and the 7900 XT
will take on the latest 4000 series from Nvidia.
While specific details and performance numbers
were not shared during the press event,
some important points
were mentioned.
AMD's cards will massively undercut
the 4000 series,
the 7900 XT retailing for 900
and the 7900 XT...
Solltest du auf die nächste PS5 Pro warten?
Ist die schon angekündigt?
Es wäre ziemlich bescheuert,
wieder eine Pro rauszubringen.
...retailing for 1000,
which is about $600 less than the RTX 4090.
These new GPUs...
Bei der letzten Konsolengeneration
ging's halt einfach nicht anders.
Es war damals schon eine blöde Idee.
Ähm, weil die SM ist so schwach gelauncht
von der Hardware,
das ist ja diese Konsolengeneration nicht.
First chiplet design.
Ja.
Wäre das einzige Spiel,
wofür sich eine PS5 aus meiner Sicht lohnen würde?
Also für mich zum Spielen
wäre das aktuelle God of War.
Modular design featuring a 5-nanometer GPU die
and a 6-nanometer memory cache die.
This makes the cards much more power efficient
compared to Nvidia's offering.
Tech outlets like Linus Tech Tips
replicated AMD's benchmarks,
which included data from last two GPUs
and used multipliers to show the new GPUs
as relative performance targets.
They concluded that the 7900 XTX
could offer roughly 90% of the RTX 4090's performance,
but we'll have to wait for real-world data
to confirm anything.
Rumors online suggest the Japanese video game giant Sega
is gearing up to ship yet another mini version
of a classic console.
The packaging...
Tja...
Ähm, was anderes kriegen sie aktuell nicht wirklich auf die Reihe.
Guckt euch mal das neue Sonic an.
Da machen sogar Hardcore Sonic Fans sich drüber lustig.
...for the Mega Mini Drive 2.
In Japan contains a link to a customer survey.
The survey consists of 47 questions,
one of which asks the customers what mini console
they'd love to see from Sega next.
The options include classic hardware like the Dreamcast,
Game Gear or another Mega Drive Mini.
Sega has previously stated that the production
on a mini Dreamcast would be costly,
but would look into it if the demand were there.
Not only are these mini console remakes great...
COSTLY?
Das kannst du heute schon wahrscheinlich um Respo...
Na wobei...
Ob du... ne... weiß ich nicht.
...how many nostalgic gamers.
Ob das auf dem Respo die Pei läuft?
...but they're also successfully introducing younger generations
to classic titles such as...
Gerade... gerade... äh... äh... äh... die...
Sega Genesis... das war ja gar nicht so schlecht von der Hardware.
Das war ja glaube ich das, was so zu Gamecube-Zeiten
irgendwie rausgekommen ist, oder?
...Wake Sonic 2, Streets of Rage and Castlevania.
Before we move on to the last topic of today's video,
let us know in the comments what you want from Ridgeline Games
and their new narrative-driven Battlefield 2.
Ach ne, Moment, Moment, nee, nee.
Genesis war... ist der Mega Drive.
Genesis ist der... ich glaub... ich glaub, ich hab's durcheinander gebracht.
Nee, nee, nee. Genesis Dreamcast
meinte ich. Dreamcast war das.
Zu Gamecube-Zeiten.
Genesis ist, das soll garantiert
über Raspberry Pi machbar sein.
Das war ja quasi
der Super Nintendo von Sega, wenn du so willst.
Gar nicht.
Tech-Demo für Sims. Leute, wir haben es geschafft.
Endlich.
Endlich eine
Sims-Tech-Demo, jawoll.
Ey, wisst ihr, wie das aussieht?
Das sieht aus wie so ein komischer Küchenbilder im Ikea.
Im Ikea stehen doch auch so
komische Dinger rum, wo du dir deine Wohnung einrichten kannst.
Das sieht fast genauso aus.
Ey, wetten! Ohne Scheiß.
Leute.
Passt mal auf.
Wetten, hier gibt es Microtransaction-Options.
So nach dem Motto,
ja, dein Sim kann entweder
zwei Monate arbeiten gehen
für einen neuen Tisch, oder
du kannst jetzt reinkashen und den in einen neuen Tisch
direkt hinstellen.
Das ist garantiert, das ist garantiert
wieder übelst
verseucht
mit irgendwelchen Payment- und so.
Ich habe außer dem ersten Sims nie einen Sims gespielt.
Das erste Sims fand ich damals vom Ansatz her wirklich
erfrischend, ja.
Danach nie wieder reingeguckt in den Sims.
Best PC-Cases of 2022.
Schauen wir mal.
Was sind die besten Cases?
Haben die alle Timestamps irgendwie so, dass man...
Ja, da unten steht es doch.
Da unten steht es doch.
Best Budget, Best Mid-Rage,
Best Mid...
Best Mid-Range Case.
Wie kein Fractal Design.
Ach hier, Best Thermals.
Aha, da, das gucken wir uns mal an.
Was sind denn, was ist denn Best Thermals?
Also die beste, beste Airflow, oder, oder...
Bei den Sims gibt es DLCs,
die zusammen über 1000 Euro sind.
Ja, die sind nicht mal ganz dicht, ja.
Die spinnen komplett.
Okay, Best PC-Case,
das muss ich mal kurz reingucken,
weil das, das steht bei...
Das will ich mir vielleicht für eine, für eine...
für den nächsten Rechner holen.
100...
Was, wie viel?
Das hat doch, gestern hat es 240 gekostet.
Ich hab da nachgeguckt.
190 bei uns kostet 240 Euro.
Keck.
Das war das erste Mal, dass ein Fractal-Torrent rausgekommen ist.
Aber Cases werden nicht wie Silikon.
Es ist immer noch nutzbar.
Es bleibt einer der am meisten beeindruckenden Cases auf dem Markt.
Und es hat sich so gut gelandet,
als Best Thermals for two years running now in our benchmarks.
And last year, we also gave it...
Machst du da erneut mit Wasserkühlung wahrscheinlich schon, ja?
...overall.
The Torrent's average CPU temperature
under a full system load
was just 41 degrees Celsius above ambient,
keeping it at the top of the chart all year.
And that's the stock configuration.
For GPU thermals, it's not a technical best,
but it's the best balanced of the options nearby.
The Torrent is within a few degrees of the top,
and it manages better CPU thermals
with a more significant weighting
than its competitors.
Die Hardwarepreise sind alles andere als gesunken.
Es ist teuer als Fax, sich neuen Rechner zu kaufen.
Also ich rechne damit,
dass ich wahrscheinlich über 4000 Euro ausgeben muss.
The Torrent is able to excel in thermals this way
because of its fan layout.
Two large and unencumbered 180mm front fans
allow the system to perform as well.
Wo würde man dort überhaupt...
Wo würde man da überhaupt den Radiator reinsetzen?
Da oben?
Oder wie?
Vorne?
Aber vorne ist der Airflow doch dann wieder kacke.
All the while offering a look that differs the Torrent
from the pack of now common mesh front panels.
140mm fans also aid in performance...
Wichtig ist, dass das Ding...
Hat das Ding einen Staubfilter?
Ist das ein Staubfilter hier?
Also wenn es keinen Staubfilter hat,
ohne Staubfilter kommt mir da nix hin.
...worth considering for anyone who can fit it in the budget.
We used it for our recent editing system build
and we even found 180mm radiators to put on the front.
This is the type of case that can last...
Ah, ah, hier, Radiator an die Front.
Anyone who can fit it in the...
Ja.
Hm.
Weiß nicht.
...the budget.
Ist das...
Aber dann ist doch der Airflow wieder nicht...
Wirkt...
Moment, hat der einen Radiator oben und unten?
We used it for our recent editing system build
and we even found 180mm radiators to put on the front.
This is the type of case that can last for multiple builds
and on the current market it's without equal in terms of thermals
while maintaining high build quality.
For those interested in...
Staubfilter sind schlecht für den Airflow, ja.
...for those interested in...
Kann sein, aber die sind gut, da ich nicht sauber machen muss.
...the Torrent, but trying to spend less,
consider the Torrent Compact as an alternative.
For many ITX, they also have a Torrent Nano,
but we haven't reviewed that one.
Best noise-normalized thermals is up next.
For this one, we're looking at the top performers
when the total system noise level is matched
at 36 dBA at 12...
Na okay, aber das Case ist anscheinend echt nicht verkehrt.
Ich muss mal schauen.
Ich bin immer noch unschlüssig,
was es denn am Ende wird.
Was ist?
Streamer abkacken.
Oh, Vodafone.
MonkaS, was ist hier los?
Einfach mal 1500 Frame Drops.
Ah, jetzt geht's wieder.
Vodafone hat zugeschlagen.
Ne, jetzt geht's wieder.
Okay, was können wir uns angucken?
Huge Fiber Upgrade.
Wiring my house mit 100 Gigabit.
Okay, wetten, das ist ein Ami-Haus.
Und das Erste, was er macht, ist eine Säge holen
und Löcher in die Wand schrauben.
Äh, Löcher in die Wand sägen, nicht schrauben.
Äh, ja, wo ist das?
Hallo?
Eine YouTube-Vorschau ist wieder pepega.
Ja, er hat einfach Löcher in die Wand gesägt, wieder mal.
Das kannst du halt in Ami-Häusern machen.
Hier wird's ein bisschen schwierig.
Wann baut er denn überhaupt was?
Der ist die ganze Zeit doch nur am Sitzen und am Erzählen.
Wo, wo, wo tut sich denn da was?
Ah, jetzt, ne, auch nicht.
Hier.
Und?
Die aktuelle Schale ist auf.
Ja, das sind irgendwelche Boxen, die sie in die Wand gesägt haben, wieder.
Weil es irgendwelche Ami-Holzwände sind.
Äh, was?
Ah, jetzt.
Ja.
Ja, das ist so typisches Ami-Haus wieder.
Ah, toll.
Das bringt, das bringt gar nix.
Das ist halt nicht praktikabel für uns hier.
Auch wieder die komischen Unify-Krempel am Start.
Was ist denn der Sinn da unten von?
Ich mein, der hat drei Geräte und irgendwie acht Schalter.
Und vor allem wozu?
Naja, gut.
Was auch immer.
Das ist natürlich ein toller Test für Gigabit, für zehn, für hundert Gigabit, mal nen Speed-Test zu machen mit 271 Mbit.
Über WLAN.
Das ist natürlich ganz besonders aussagekräftig.
Das ist viel mehr Uplink als das Switch braucht.
Aber es...
Okay, sinnlos Video.
Weißt du, ich hab 100 Gigabit Netzwerk, aber was mach ich?
Ich mach einen Speed-Test über WLAN.
alles klar 6 hat so muss man das ausprobieren so nicht anders dass die
holzwahn überhaupt den schrank hält ja das war doch ein weg was auf dem boden
stand du meinst der netzwerkschrank ja tatsächlich wer weiß er ist bestimmt
konzert task groups brand new and insanely useful
ja gott vor fünf ist 5 überhaupt das theoretisch gott vor fünf
ich glaube es theoretisch gott vor fünf also das ist wirklich eines der wenigen
spiele wo ich mich seit jahren jetzt darauf freue aber ich kann es halt nicht
spielen weil ps5 und ich sehe es nicht ein ps5 zu kaufen gottes abbild
dankeschön für den sub aber bringt halt nichts weil ich will keine ps5 kaufen
nur für ein game
was ist das mit eurem consultant hast ja verdient viewtify 3 ist haben sie es
endlich geschafft weiß nur irgendwie eineinhalb jahre oder zwei jahre nach
view 3 release das wollten sie übrigens glaube ich schon anfang des jahres
release dieses meisterwerk hat nur eine schwäche lass mich raten dass es
irgendwann mal vorbei ist ich hoffe die games da spoilert nicht normalerweise
geben sie sich immer verhältnismäßig ja ja wenn er ja
eigentlich geben ja sie sagen immer es ist bolt frei aber irgendwie doch doch
oft nicht also insofern also wir können uns entweder das angucken das segunda
scores games da video an wir gucken uns das games re再見 hoffen dass sie
nicht spoilern es ok habe schon angeschaut okay also
willkommen gespoilert als glas druck kommt gleich gleich schon der erste
spoiler dass das ist die die dicks ja aus dem aus dem letzten teil die mutter
von dem Typ, den man am Ende gekillt hat.
Als nach 30 Stunden
der Abspann des neuen God of War
läuft, müssen wir erstmal tief
durchatmen. Denn das, was Santa Monica
Studio da abgeliefert hat, ist
ohne... Eins muss man ja auch denen wirklich
zugute halten. Ich glaube, es gab noch kein
wirklich schlechtes God of War
von der Main-Serie. Ja, über
den Mobile-Ableger und dann
das Remake davon auf der PS4
oder was war, kann man sich vielleicht streiten,
aber insgesamt die Main-God of War
Titel waren alle richtig gut.
Wenn man so Games mag.
Aber eigentlich
ist das auch sehr zugänglich.
Also eigentlich kann es jeder mögen.
Leute, ich spoiler...
Was ich spoilere, ist das letzte Game,
was vier Jahre alt ist.
Also wer das jetzt noch nicht gespielt hat
und sich jetzt ein Review zum Nachfahren...
Also ich weiß nicht.
Denn die zweite Reise von Kratos und Atreus
durch die nordische Mythenwelt ist
so vollgepackt mit coolen
Überraschungen, dass es wirklich schade
wäre, wenn wir euch die verderben
würden.
Ich bin zur Neugier durchaus fähig.
Deshalb haben sich...
...und ich dazu entschlossen,
dieses Testvideo maximal
spoilerfrei zu halten. Ja, so muss es sein.
Ich habe euch hier nur das Nötigste,
damit ihr all diese Dinge selbst erleben könnt.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt dafür Verständnis
und seid gleichzeitig so fair,
anderen auch nichts zu spoilern.
Wo bleibt denn da die Überraschung?
Nur um eine Sache
kommen wir nicht herum.
Ihr solltet sowohl für dieses Video
als auch für das eigentliche Spiel
das God of War von 2018
durchgespielt haben.
Zwar gibt es in Ragnarök zu Beginn eine kleine
Zusammenfassung, die enthält aber wirklich
nur das Nötigste und...
Ich meine, so viel passiert ist jetzt ja eigentlich...
Wenn man mal so die Story zusammenfassen will,
so viel passiert ist ja eigentlich
im letzten God of War gar nicht, ja?
Kratos ist jetzt irgendwie in Skandinavien
und hat einen Sohn,
und die Mutter ist gestorben
und sie wollen jetzt die Asche auf einen Berg bringen
und dann kommt am Anfang irgendein Fremder
zu ihm ins Haus und dann kloppen sie sich
und dann machen sie sich auf den Weg,
die Asche zu verstreuen
und dabei bringen sie ein paar Götter um
und am Ende, sie kriegen geholfen von Freya
und Freyas Sohn ist der Böse
und der Endgegner im ersten Teil,
der wird dann gekillt und dann ist sie sauer
und am Ende kommt raus, dass Atreus quasi Loki ist
und Kratos der Vater von Loki.
So, das ist die Story von God of War 2018.
Easy.
Das war's eigentlich.
Im Prinzip war's das.
Boah.
Dieses Video wird euch präsentiert von Clark.
Ein Unfall.
Alter.
Die Games natürlich.
Wobei ich darf nichts sagen.
Ich habe letztens Matchmaster,
das beworben, ja.
Ähm...
Das ist eine gute Frage, Chat.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher,
was die eigentlich gegen Kratos haben.
Ich überlege gerade.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was die eigentlich gegen Kratos
überhaupt haben.
Gute Frage. Nächste Frage.
Kann man so ein Cyberport oder
LastMinute.de einlösen?
Übrigens, so viele Götter bringt man, glaube ich, gar nicht,
um in God of War
2000...
War, glaube ich, 2018 oder so.
Ähm... Man bringt irgendwie
irgendeinen Sohn von Thor
bringt man, glaube ich, um.
Ähm...
Baldur bringt man um.
Diese komische Schlange hilft einem, ja,
weil sie die Götter auch nicht abkann.
Ähm...
Ich glaube, das war's.
Ich glaube, das war's sogar.
Egal. Wir gucken jetzt das
Review fertig.
Und sind wir auch stehen geblieben.
Ja. Clark. Dein Versicherungsmanager.
Also, meiner ist es nett.
Ja, und das ist dieser
allwissende Typ, den man im ersten Teil...
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, warum man den sich geholt hat.
Nee, ist das nicht der Typ, der in die Zukunft guckt?
Ach.
Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Drei Jahre sind seit der Reise von Kratos und Atreus
auf den höchsten Gipfel Jötunheims
vergangen. Dort hat er das Duo
die Asche von Kratos...
Übrigens, hat er nicht am Ende vom letzten God of War sogar
seine... Äh, wie heißt das?
Diese Ketten weggeworfen?
Und dieses Game hat er sie wieder, okay.
...über die Riesenlande
verteilt. Seitdem hält
der Fimbulwinter Midgard mit
seinen Schneemassen fest im eisigen
Griff und dann wäre da natürlich auch
noch Ragnarök. Das
große nordische Göttersterben,
das Ende aller Tage,
das einer Prophezeiung nach auch den
Tod von Kratos bedeutet.
Doch während die Ausgangslage
für Vater und Sohn zugegeben düsterer
kaum sein könnte... Naja, Kratos ist ja am Ende
von God of War 3 schon gestorben und war dann
wieder am Start. Ich weiß nicht, wurde das überhaupt
jemals erklärt?
Warum Kratos
God of War 3 überlebt hat?
Ich glaub nicht, oder?
Weil das Ende von God of War 3 ist ja,
Kratos bringt Zeus um und er sticht
sich dann selbst.
So, und...
Warum lebt der eigentlich wieder?
Oh, Chaos, wurscht, der lebt!
Das ist unsterblich.
Kann ihm nix passieren.
Für die Geschichte von God of War Ragnarök
ist sie ein großer Segen.
Denn jetzt geht's ans Eingemachte.
Und zwar in allen neuen
Welten der nordischen Mythologie.
Ja, die dürfen wir diesmal nämlich alle bereisen.
Es geht in der Story um schicksalhafte
Entscheidungen und die zu
erleben ist speziell im letzten
Spieldrittel das wirklich vollgepackt
mit... F? Nee, nix F.
Ja, keine Framethrower.
Fragischen Momenten ist ein riesengroßer
Genuss.
Der Soundtrack soll auch wieder
ziemlich gut sein.
Aha.
Von der reinen Inszenierung, der spannenden
Mythensage und der Charaktertiefe vieler
Nebenfiguren und Antagonisten ist Ragnarök
ein absolutes Meisterwerk.
Eines, das wir übrigens wahlweise mit einer
hervorragenden deutschen oder englischen
Symbolik... Ich hab was gehört.
Was bei Hel ist das überhaupt?
Das ist mein Sohn.
Was?
Den Jorn Smeeders Namen ist mit ihm
passiert. Er ist
jetzt viel zu groß
und sieht jetzt
so aus.
Ist deine Schuld.
Und noch besser, Ragnarök kommt mit einem
orchestralen Soundtrack daher, der uns
gleich mehrfach die Gänsehaut auf den
Arm gezaubert hat. Also der Soundtrack war immer
wirklich gut. Das muss man sagen. Alle
God of Wars hatten super Soundtracks. Kann man
sich unabhängig vom Game heute noch geben.
An der Story zu kritteln
haben wir aber leider auch. Denn wie bereits
der Vorgänger leidet auch Ragnarök
speziell im Mittel... Spielt ihr mit deutscher oder englischer? Also ich würde es auf jeden Fall
auf Englisch spielen. Teil an deutlich spürbaren
Problemen mit dem Pacing und
verstrickt sich immer wieder in Nebenschauplätze,
die uns aus der spannenden Handlung reißen.
Eine straffere Story hätte...
Wahrscheinlich muss es das Game, weil ansonsten wäre es
in 10 Stunden durch, anstatt
40 oder so. Generell wirkt Ragnarök
in Teilen unnötig gestreckt,
was unter anderem an häufigen Backtracking
Passagen liegt, die gerade ab der Mitte
des Spiels sehr unschön auffällt.
Hier auch eine kleine Empfehlung für euch.
Verlasst die recht linearen Hauptpfade
der Geschichte für kleine und normale
Schatztruhen nicht allzu häufig.
Sie ziehen das Spiel in die Länge und bringen
oft nur Ressourcen, die eh im Überfluss
vorhanden sind. Erst recht, wenn ihr euch
mit Nebenaufgaben die Zeit vertreibt.
Zu denen kommen wir aber später noch.
Ist halt die Frage, ob man nicht...
Ich mein...
Belohnung bei Neben...
Sidetracking ist halt das eine so,
aber man sieht halt auch was von der Spielwelt,
was ja ein großer Teil von so
Games mittlerweile ist. Wobei ich gelesen hab,
dass das neue God of War kein
Open-World-Game im klassischen Sinne ist,
sondern quasi eher
mehrere große Areale hat.
Was ich ja persönlich gut finde,
weil es muss nicht alles Open-World sein, um Open-World
zu sein. Einfach nur um Open-World zu sein.
... nicht ganz so stark ins Gewicht fällt,
liegt in erster Linie an den durchweg
fantastisch geschriebenen Dialogen.
Kratos, Atreus und andere Figuren
haben immer was zu erzählen und es macht
einfach Spaß, den teils humorvollen,
teils von Leid erfüllten Dialogen
zu erzählen.
Ich habe dich tagelang
wach bleiben sehen, ohne dass dir die Augen
zufallen. Du döst nicht mal.
Götter dösen nicht.
Sag das mal Thor.
Richtig klasse ist auch, dass selbst kleine
Anspielungen und Hinweise aus Teil 1
in God of War Ragnarök wortwörtlich
große Spuren hinterlassen haben.
Falls sich übrigens Sorgen um den
technischen Zustand macht, können wir für
beide Plattformen Entwarnung geben.
God of War Ragnarök erscheint zum Release
in einem fertigen Zustand und lässt
uns auf der PS5 die Wahl zwischen
5 Grafikmodi, die uns ein
flüssiges Spielerlebnis in 60...
Okay, Sekunde, Sekunde. Was haben wir hier?
30 FPS oder 60 FPS
und dafür, gut, die Auflösung
reicht ja.
Was HFR?
Was zum Teufel ist HFR?
Ist das HDR?
Ist das HDR nur anders geschrieben?
Oder was ist High...
High Rendering? Was ist HFR?
Und was ist VRR?
Ach, da unten steht es ja.
Da unten steht es. High Frame Rate?
Variable Refresh Rate?
Na dann.
Tja, ich habe eine PS4.
Ich könnte es theoretisch auf der
normalen PS4 spielen, aber
1080p 30 FPS und
wahrscheinlich schlechtere Grafik?
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Dann warte ich lieber, bis es auf den PC kommt
und ich spiele es auf dem PC jetzt, wenn ich
mir schon so einen teuren neuen PC kaufe.
... sich FPS bescheren.
Auch das haptische Feedback und die
Funktionen des DualSense wurden beispielsweise
bei Kratos Axtwurf sinnvoll eingebunden.
Und lass uns die wuchtigen Kämpfe
noch mehr spüren.
Von Bugs wurden wir übrigens nahezu
komplett verschont. Um wenige
Neustarts haben wir zwar nicht herum...
Wobei, so viel später kam das doch.
God of War PC Release?
Äh...
Wann kam das auf dem PC raus? 2018 nicht?
Das ist später.
Ihr könnt es nun endlich auf dem PC spielen.
Oh, okay. Wirklich drei Jahre
später? Keck?
Letztes Jahr im Januar.
Irgendwie Anfang letzten Jahres.
Aber es kam wirklich drei Jahre nach Release erst auf den PC.
Na gut. Dauert noch ein bisschen.
Die waren dank der fair platzierten Rücksetzpunkte
aber nicht weiter wild.
Kollege Chris hat sich für euch außerdem
die PS4-Version angeschaut und ist auch
hier voll des Lobes. Auf der alten
Hardware sind zwar nur 30 FPS
möglich, die hält Ragnarök aber auch
in den hektischen Kämpfen stabil.
Dabei weiß auch die Bildqualität zu überzeugen,
die nah an der PS5 ist.
Was die
PS5-Optik anbelangt, ihr
seht es ja selbst. Optisch ist
Ragnarök von Kratos detaillierter Rüstung
bis zum tollen Artdesign der Spielwelten
und Gegner ein überaus
hübsches Spiel. Dass wir hier einen
Cross-Gen-Titel haben, merkt man im Spiel nur ganz
selten an. Klar, die Gesichtsanimationen
sind nicht auf höchstem PS5-Niveau
eines The Last of Us Part 1 und
Ladezeiten werden bei solchen
quetschdicht durch die Felsenpassagen auch
kaschiert, aber hey, hier meckern wir schon
auf ganz hohem Niveau.
Irgendwo musst du es laden. Apropos ganz hohem Niveau, wie wir es bereits aus
aktuellen Playstation-Exklusiv-Spielen
wie Horizon Forbidden West und The Last of Us Part 1
kennen, findet ihr direkt im
Hauptmenü eine vorbildliche Auswahl
an Barriereformen. Bekommt man eigentlich
mittlerweile eine PS5?
Das God of War Bundle
heißt...
Jetzt übertreibt
halt mal! Übertreibt halt mal!
Das ist schon ganz schön
teuer, oder? Aber gut,
ich mein...
Aber es gibt ja auch keine
Games, warum sollte ich mir eine PS5 kaufen?
Es gibt keinen Sinn.
Ich mein...
Es gibt ein Spiel, was ich dafür spielen würde.
Es gibt ja... Da habe ich ja weniger Spiele als auf der Switch
dann.
Freiheitsoptionen.
Von Farbfiltern über Bewegungshilfen bis hin
zu Rätselunterstützung und Hochkontrastanzeigen.
Ihr könnt hier eine riesige
Menge anpassen.
Doch weg von der Story, weg von den Hilfen
kommen wir zu dem hier.
Oh ja!
Dem unfassbar wuchtigen
Kampfsystem. Hier übrigens
zuallererst die ganz wichtige Info
für Fans der frühen God of War Spiele,
die im Vorgänger die Vielzahl an
epischen Bosskämpfen vermisst haben.
Die Anzahl wurde DEUTLICH
erhöht und was ihr hier seht, ist
noch einer der unspektakulärsten Scharmützel,
die übrigens manchmal
auch ganz schön fördern können.
Generell wurde von
blitzespuckenden Echsen bis hin zum
Zentauro-ähnlichen Pirscher deutlich
an der Gegnervielfalt geschraubt
und es scheint, dass hätte Kratos bereits
die Vorgänger jeden Troll aus den
neuen Welten verjagt.
Okay, ganz korrekt ist das nicht.
Einem Troll sind wir dann doch begegnet,
aber formulieren wir es so,
Game Director Eric Williams und sein
Team haben sich den Kritikpunkt offensichtlich
zu Herzen genommen und bei uns
für einen großen Lacher gesorgt.
Doch nicht nur an diesem Punkt wurde
gefeilt. Insgesamt sind die Kämpfe
über das Spiel hinweg eine ganze Spur
abwechslungsreicher, auf Wunsch taktischer
und auch dank brutaler Finisher
eine ganze Ecke blutiger.
Wo wir beim Thema
Abwechslung sind.
In Ragnarök gibt es zwei weitere
Varianten der Spartan Rage,
mit der wir unter anderem Kratos
Gesundheit regenerieren.
Wir haben neue Schilde gefunden,
mit denen wir besser parieren,
eine Menge Schaden abblocken oder sie
für einen Angriff aufladen können.
Sicher ist euch auch aufgefallen,
dass unser liebster Spartaner jetzt
weit agiler ist und sich beispielsweise
mit seinen Chaos-Klingen an markierten
Stellen hochzieht und von Plattformen
Feinde herabspringt.
Auch allerhand neue Kampffähigkeiten
kann unser liebster Wüterich erlernen.
Welche Attacken zur Wahl stehen,
ist dabei erneut an das jeweilige Level
der Waffen gekoppelt, die wir in der
Zwergenschmiede von Brokk und Sindri
mit gefundenen Ressourcen aufwerten.
Einzig, dass uns Ragnarök
wie bereits im Vorhinein
zu viele Erfahrungspunkte anhand
des Spiels der Story belohnt und sie
gegen Ende des Spiels obsolet macht,
hätte besser gelöst und für mehr
Motivation sorgen können.
Mit der Axt oder den Chaos-Klingen
das Kampfsystem aus God of War Ragnarök
muss sich hinter keinem Actionspiel verstecken.
Einen nicht unwichtigen Anteil daran
hat aber auch Atreus, der drei Jahre
und zahlreiche Kämpfe später zur überaus
hilfreichen Unterstützung im Kampf
gereift ist. Der gute
Boy teilt nicht nur Schaden aus,
sondern schickt auch imposante Zauber
aufs Schlachtfeld. Hier eine kleine
Postprobe.
Wie bereits im Vorgänger wird
Boy hat ja mal ne Zeit lang
auf Twitch gestreamt.
Weiß nicht, ob der noch aktiv ist, der hat Fortnite gestreamt
auf Twitch.
...aber nicht nur gekämpft, sondern auch gerätselt.
Auf die cleveren Knogeleien treffen wir in regelmäßigen
Abständen im Verlauf der Geschichte,
wo wir beispielsweise zum Öffnen eines Durchgangs
Wasserfrontänen in korrekter Reihenfolge
mit Kratos-Axt einfrieren müssen.
Oh, ich glaub ich hab's.
Wenn man den Geysir einfriert, dreht der Druck
das Rad.
High-IQ-Rätsel.
Eh, coole Leute,
coole Leute machen die Kiste
halb rückwärts und nur mit einem Arm auf.
So, ja, natürlich.
So macht man immer Kisten auf, exakt.
So macht man nur Kisten auf, wenn hier die Kamera
ist, dass die Kamera reingucken kann
und nicht durch Kratos durchglitscht.
Aber gut, hey, es ist ein Game.
Aber er sieht stylisch aus.
Doch nicht nur das Kampfsystem
wurde ordentlich aufgepumpt.
Generell ist God of War Ragnarök
in Sachen Umfang ein wahrer
Riese. Und das liegt nicht nur
an der überaus ordentlichen Spielzeit
der Geschichte. Erstmals
können wir von der feurigen Hölle Muspelheim
über die farbenfrohe Zwergenwelt
Svartalfheim bis nach Asgard
alle neun Welten
mit Abstrichen erkunden.
Mit Abstrichen, da nicht alle
Reiche mit großen, offenen Hubs
versehen sind. In Niflheim
finden wir beispielsweise lediglich eine Kampfarena,
in der wir ohne Schaden zu erleiden
unsere Attacken üben können und
diesen wunderschönen Rabenbaum hier.
Odins Späher sind erneut
in den Welten zu finden und warten darauf,
dass wir sie mit der Axt vom Himmel holen.
Am Rabenbaum winkt dann
Peter!
Das ist eine überaus wertvolle Belohnung
für Kratos. Wie schon im Vorgänger
sammelt ihr im Verlauf des Abenteuers wieder
verschiedene Rüstungen, die ihr genau wie
die Waffen auch bei Sindri und Brokk
verbessern könnt.
An dieser Stelle übrigens
eine coole Info für alle, die bei Kratos
viel Wert aufs Äußere legen.
Was für einen Monitor hast du eigentlich? 21 zu 9?
Ne, 16 zu 9
und auch nur 1080p.
Aber mit dem neuen Rechner, wenn ich den
dann mal hab.
Gibt's wahrscheinlich im OLED-Display.
Endlich gibt's ein
Transmog-System.
Wer will, kann sich aber locker flockig
weit über 50 Stunden
mit dem Action-Adventure die Zeit vertreiben,
dabei besondere Ausrüstung einsammeln
und durchaus auch abseits der Hauptpfade
Spaß haben. Da hätten
wir interessante Nebenmissionen, in denen wir
beispielsweise mehr über Mimias düstere
Vergangenheit erfahren und auch zahlreiche
fordernde Challenges, die den Walkürenkämpfen
ähneln und in denen wir unser
erlerntes Können im Kampf auf die Probe stellen.
Allerdings sind nicht alle Missionen
ihre Zeit wert. Bei so manchen
Banditenlagern oder der ein oder anderen
Töte-X-Monster-Mission
wurde mir wieder daran erinnert, dass Ragnarök
nicht nur während der Story doch etwas
zu stark aufgeblasen wurde.
Aber weil das alles rein optional
ist, drücken wir hier gern mal ein Auge
zu. Erst recht, wenn sich unter den
Nebenaufgaben auch allerhand lohnende
Perlen verstecken.
Das Gefühl
in God of War Ragnarök von Aufgaben
überflutet zu werden, hatten
wir hingegen nie. Einige Bereiche
der Open Hubs werden im Stil eines Metroidvania
erst durch ein neues Gadget
freigeschaltet und auch so manche
Truhe bleibt ohne den nötigen Zauber
über viele Stunden hinweg verschlossen.
So was finde ich
eigentlich immer ganz gut. Da musst du dann im Hinterkopf
haben, ah, da habe ich noch was vergessen.
Das macht dann, wenn man backtracken muss, das
irgendwie ein bisschen spannender. Ja, aber je nachdem,
wie ich mal gucke.
Ich, also ganz im Ernst, ich würde es wirklich
gerne spielen, aber ich will mir keine PS5
für ein Game kaufen.
Daher lohnt es sich im späteren
Verlauf des Spiels nochmal... Ja, ich könnte es auf der
PS4 spielen, aber ich habe eine PS4
nicht pro.
Also das weiß ich nicht, ob ich mir das geben kann.
...zurückzukehren. Denn wer weiß,
welche Geschichte oder welch packender
Bosskampf hinter der zuvor
unüberwindbaren Klippe lauert. Hat der Boy
eine neue Stimme? Nee,
ich glaube, da ist einfach auch Real Life ein bisschen
später geworden. Da lauert
wirklich so einiges.
PS Now Cloud Gaming.
So blöd ist
die Idee glaube ich gar nicht.
Moment, PS Now
PC, warte mal.
Ich glaube, so doof ist die Idee gar nicht.
Kann ich?
PlayStation Plus.
Hier erfährst du, wie du
PlayStation Plus spielst
auf deinem PC streamst.
Das Game ist nicht drinne.
Ne, die wollen damit Konsolen verkaufen, oder?
Ne, ne, das kannst du vergessen.
Will be on PS Plus.
No.
Gut, das heißt,
ich kann es nicht auf dem PC spielen und ich muss mir
eine Konsole kaufen. Na geil.
Ne, da kaufe ich mir keine Konsole.
...Ragnarök ausmacht,
klingt also sehr vertraut.
Deshalb können wir durchaus verstehen,
wenn da in den Kommentarspalten
das ist doch nur God of War 1.5
gespottet wird. Du googelst
wie ein Boomer. Ich bin
ein Boomer. Und außerdem, wie sieht das
bitte schön aus?
Wie zeichnet sich
Boomer-Googling aus?
...God of War von 2018
weht mit Ragnarök nicht durch
die inzwischen 17 Jahre alte
Actionserie. Da war alles
neu, Kratos hatte sich von einer anderen
Seite gezeigt, die Interaktion des Vater-Sohn-Gespanns
gab es so noch nie und Gameplay
und Setting hoben sich deutlich
von den früheren Abenteuern des Spartaners
ab. Es ist richtig, dass sich
die ersten Spielstunden von Ragnarök
sehr vertraut anfühlen.
Aber lasst euch davon nicht täuschen,
denn während das bekannt
großartige Kampfsystem und die Welterkundung
euch von Anfang an reinziehen,
Was war das? Dein Bogen!
hat Ragnarök noch eine Menge
Überraschungen in der Hinterhand.
Trotz aller Längen im Mittelteil und dem
gelegentlichen Backtracking gelingt es dem Spiel
nämlich, seine spannende Story
zu einem epischen Ende zu führen
und dabei gleich mehrere Kritikpunkte
auszulösen.
Ragnarök ist nicht nur ein
verdammt gutes God of War,
sondern ein Musterbeispiel dafür,
wie die Fortsetzung zu einem absoluten
Action-Meilenstein auszusehen hat.
Tja, ohne
Konsole ist da nix.
Ich würde es gerne spielen, aber ich will
mir einfach keine PS5 kaufen.
Ich werde die Konsole nicht
verwenden.
Leute, ich habe mir eine Xbox One damals gekauft
und eine PS4. Das war der
größte Fehlkauf überhaupt.
Ich habe beides quasi nicht benutzt.
Da habe ich ja schon mehr
die Switch benutzt und die habe ich auch kaum benutzt.
Also,
jetzt eine PS5 für nur ein Game?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ne.
Ne, ne.
Können wir das Level Cap Video
anschauen? Oh, ne.
Das ist doch bestimmt wieder
nur krasses G-Bait, oder?
Das ist doch wieder
typischer Level Cap Schwachsinn, oder?
Das eine hat doch mit dem anderen
überhaupt nichts zu tun. Battlefield. Wisst ihr, was das einzige
ist, was Battlefield gekillt hat?
Das ist Battlefield selbst.
Weil sie ein Kack-Game released haben.
Qualität
setzt sich durch und das hat das Game
einfach nicht gehabt.
Ich werde mich nicht dazu äußern, wo ich meine Ausbildung
gemacht habe, beziehungsweise wo ich gerade bin.
Wäre ja blöd.
Warum sollte ich jetzt, warum sollte ich da
10 Jahre aufpassen, dass
ich nicht zu viel über mich leake und
jetzt irgendwie großartig was erzähle?
Also, wie gesagt, ich würde es gerne spielen, aber
keine Chance. Also,
PS5 wird nicht gekauft.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Fireship Video.
Uni statt Großstadt.
Das Gehalt als Juraprofessor fürs
Lehren und Forschen. Lohnt sich das?
Das gucken wir jetzt.
I build a massive cat wall
for my cats and raccoons.
Raccoons sind das
Meerschweinchen?
Ne.
Waschbären? Sind das Waschbären?
Waschbären? Oh.
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Hey everyone, we have
Alter, ist das Daily Dose
of Internet?
Hey everyone, we have
Ey, das hört sich original an.
Hey everyone,
Hello everyone, this is
Ne, ne, ne, doch nicht. Aber ähnlich, aber ähnlich.
Ähnlich, ähnlich.
Es ist im Prinzip einfach nur ein überdimensionaler
Kratzbaum, oder wie?
Na gut, was soll's
auch sonst sein?
Und warum sind hier Kratzbäume immer
original mit diesen, das sind immer
die gleichen Teile. Das sind immer so
Holzdinger mit Strick drum gewickelt
zum Kratzen.
Könnte man doch irgendwie mal ein bisschen
anders designen.
Jeder Kratzbaum sieht so aus.
Also Chico wäre das egal,
wenn ich sowas hinstellen würde. Die würde sich das
angucken und sagen, ich kletter doch da jetzt nicht rauf.
What the fuck?
Warum ist seine Wand magnetisch?
An manchen Stellen.
Ist das auch wieder so ein
Ami-Ding? Schrauben.
What?
Warum kann der Magnete einfach an die Wand machen?
Ach, weil da in der Mitte
irgendwelche Metallhalterungen
für die Wand sind, oder wie?
Ah, okay, okay.
Und jetzt hat er sich das Metall rausgesucht und er bohrt dort
direkt, wo das Metall ist? Ich check's grad nicht.
Oh, oh. Die arme
Schraube, MonkaS.
Jetzt wissen wir auch, wozu man eine
Grafikkarte braucht mit Wasserwaage.
Dass wenn die mal nicht mehr aktuell ist, dass man sowas
damit verwenden kann.
Oh, oh, oh.
Das Bessere wäre wahrscheinlich
nicht so ultra
auf Drehzahl draufzudrücken
von dem Ding und in Bit zu nehmen, der besser
in die Schraube passt.
Aber gut, es hält, es hält. Das ist das Wichtige.
Okay, so spannend
ihm jetzt zuzugucken, wie er es an die Wand schraubt,
ist es auch nicht.
Oh, das tut ja weh beim Zuhören schon.
Okay, jetzt gibt's irgendwie so eine Hängematte.
Bekommt ihr auch teilweise auf YouTube
irgendwelche Handwerk, irgendwelche
Tool- und Handwerkstipp-Shorts
angezeigt von irgendwelchen
Indern, die ganz, ganz furchtbar
abstruses Zeug machen.
Und das hat dann irgendwie 30 Millionen
Views. So, letztens
habe ich so einen Short empfohlen bekommen.
Der hat Glas in
ein Loch, also der hat ein Loch
gebohrt und hat Glas
in das Loch gefüllt und hat dann irgendwie
gesagt, jetzt hält, damit hält das
viel besser. Totaler, totaler Blödsinn.
Oder irgendeiner, der
wollte irgendwie ein Rohr verlängern
und hat festgestellt,
dass sein Verlängerungsrohr
nicht reinpasst und
dann hat er das Rohr irgendwie
breiter gemacht mit irgendeinem
ja, weiß nicht, was das ist, irgendeinem
Bohreraufsatz und
danach war das Rohr irgendwie schon halb ausgefranst,
wo ich mir gedacht habe, was zum Teufel bin
ich da sehend wieder?
Oh, das tut weh!
So, und jetzt?
Noch ist das nur ein recht großer
Kratzbaum. Und ich fertig.
Kleber?
Moment, ich muss mal kurz vorspulen.
Ah, ja.
Das wiederum könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass das Chico
gefallen würde, so eine Hängebrücke.
Das ist der Begrenzer.
Ach, das ist, dass das quasi
nicht fester, nicht zu fest dreht
oder so. Das macht
meiner auch, aber der macht andere Geräusche.
Also, wenn ich bei mir
den Drehmoment einstelle?
Na doch, das macht auch so ähnliche Geräusche, ja.
Tatsächlich.
Na doch.
Ah.
Doch, der
Kopf springt.
Letztendlich ist es ja egal, es hält und gut ist.
Es hört sich aber irgendwie ungesund an.
Wir müssen uns das jetzt nicht komplett angucken.
Ich will eigentlich nur wissen... Ah, guck mal, hier!
Jetzt, hier ist er auf die Katz drauf.
Boah.
Also, Chico wird sich erstmal nicht trauen, aber ich glaube,
so eine Hängebrücke würde der gefallen.
So eine Hängebrücke durchs Wohnzimmer oder so, das fände ich schon geil.
Also, ich sag euch,
was meine machen würde, ist folgendes.
Die würde auf die Brücke laufen und sich jetzt erstmal
in die Mitte legen für eine Stunde.
Und da ein bisschen hängen.
Ein bisschen abhängen.
Also, ganz trau zu dem Ding noch nicht, hier.
Ne,
das ist mir nix.
Oh, das ist auch ganz
schöner, ganz schöner Jonker hier unten, oder?
Da sind die so ordentlich.
Die denkt sich,
oh ne, ich soll da jetzt hochklettern.
Monka ist
klettern.
Ich bin
zu dick zum Klettern.
Die nicht, die unten.
Und die da hinten
denkt sich,
welche Low-IQ-Aktionen
laufen denn da wieder im Flur?
Gleich fällt sie runter.
Das muss reichen.
Das muss reichen. Genug Bewegung.
Genug Bewegung.
Die hüpft gleich wieder runter.
Oder muss die Brücke
erst mal verteidigt werden.
Die ist nicht dick, die hat einfach nur viel Fell,
glaube, aber die andere sieht ein bisschen zu dick aus.
Aber Katze ist auch so, wenn die älter werden,
die neigen dazu, auch ein bisschen dicker zu werden.
Also, meine ist jetzt auch nicht
super fett, aber die dünnste ist auch nicht.
Ist aber noch im Rahmen. Guck, ist alles okay.
Oh.
Das kann schon mal passieren.
Ach, das ist jetzt
der Waschbär, okay.
Der Waschbär ist ungefähr genauso dick wie die Katze.
He.
Hehehe.
Sag mal, wie viel haben die denn? Ein Hund,
drei Katzen und zwei Waschbären.
Da ist aber was los, ey.
Da hast du keine Ruhe.
Halber Zoo, ja.
Echt so.
So, der knabbert jetzt erst mal da irgendwie
die Liege durch.
Diese Kack-YouTube-Musik. Ja, das ist so
wirklich so 0815.
Okay, der find's geil.
Dem geht da einer ab drauf.
Moment, das ist noch gar nicht fertig.
Ich dachte, das ist schon alles fertig gebaut.
Nee, nee. Geht noch weiter.
Dauert drei Tage aufzubauen.
Oh.
Jetzt kommt High-IQ-Installation hier.
Wird diagonal
skaliert.
Da würde mich Chico
auslachen, wenn ich zu der Sache hüpfe, da mal rüber.
Vor allem, wo sollen die hin? Dann hier wieder
runter oder wie?
Da würde mich Chico auslachen. Da würde Chico sagen,
hast du sie noch? Alter, da geh ich doch nicht drauf.
Im Leben würde da Chico nicht draufgehen.
Warum haben sie
sie einfach nicht gleich aufgebaut, komplett?
Na gut, wahrscheinlich,
weil die Viecher gedacht haben, ey, was geht da
im Flur? Ich muss da mal drauf.
Chico hätte das auch gleich begutachtet.
Ist das Verletzungsrisiko
nicht hoch? Nee,
was soll man sich da verletzen? Großartig.
Weil die sind ja nicht doof.
Weil Katzen können klettern, ja, und Waschbären auch.
Der Hund nicht. Aber ansonsten, was soll
man sich da groß... Und selbst wenn die Katz
von da oben runterfällt, da passiert ja nix.
Verletzungsrisiko
vielleicht für ihn, wenn er sich da Kopf
dran anhaut. Moment,
das ist nochmal ne andere Katz, oder?
Die haben
vier. Die haben
vier Katzen. Die haben
die vom Anf... Die haben die Anf... Die haben diese
Graue vom Anfang.
Die haben die Weiße,
die haben die Schwarzweiße und die haben die Schwarze.
Vier Katzen, ein Hund,
zwei Waschbären.
Katzen haben kaum
Falldamage, korrekt.
Oder ist das die gleiche vom Anfang?
Ich erkenne es jetzt nicht genau. Es kommt immer ein bisschen aufs
Licht an. Immer
noch nicht fertig. Ey, da bist du ja
wirklich ne Woche beschäftigt.
Also, ich glaube, Chico wird
sich das Ding einmal angucken und nie verwenden.
Die ist so faul, was das angeht.
Oh, guck mal!
Die Dicke hat's auch geschafft.
Nee, ich
glaub... Nee, das ist ne andere Katz. Guck, die hat
weiße Pfoten und ist so...
Ich glaube, das sind wirklich ne andere.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass um diese Brücke hier
ab und zu mal
ein bisschen Gerangel entsteht.
Dass dann der Waschbär da drauf liegt und die Katz schmeißt
ihn runter oder umgedreht oder die Katz schmeißt
sich untereinander runter.
Da gibt's dann... Da gibt's Stress.
Ja, okay, erstmal den Bobbes
putzen, alles klar.
Die Katze aus Mainz, gehst
du weg? Okay, nice.
Also, im Prinzip...
Im Prinzip war das jetzt einfach
ein 14 Minuten Sponsoring für dieses
Ding hier.
Na gut.
Ja...
Das war sehr anstrengend alles.
Oh, ich hab Hunger, Leute.
Pippo-Fat-Time.
Das können wir uns doch angucken. Wollen wir uns was Kurzes angucken?
Wollen wir uns doch den Uni-Professor angucken?
Was verdient man...
Was verdient man als Juraprofessor?
Vom 11 Minuten, das
geht noch. Ich hoffe, die haben keine
Monka-Toss-Musik da drin.
Als Juristen bitte im Beruf
pissig sein und im Leben ein fröhlicher Mensch.
Gute Erklärung.
Das ist eine gute Erklärung.
Als Juristen
bitte im Beruf pissig sein und im Leben ein fröhlicher Mensch.
Mein Vater hat mir mal früher
einen Floh ins Ohr gesetzt, dass Anwälte
viel Geld verdienen und wenig arbeiten würden
und dicke Autos fahren würden.
Das wollte er auch.
Mein Name ist Martin Mattis, ich bin 46 Jahre alt,
Universitätsprofessor in Augsburg
im Fachbereich Jura.
Dann starte ich mal den Tag.
Ich gehe eigentlich jeden Tag
erst mal zum Frühstück
schon mal Anzug anhaben.
So muss das sein.
Quark und Blaubeeren.
Wie so jeden Morgen
geht's dann
mit dem Frühstück...
Ist das ein Drucker?
Nee, oder?
Was ist das hier daneben?
Das ist kein Drucker, oder?
Was ist denn das?
Ein Grill! Ah, okay.
Sieht aus wie ein Tintenstrahltrusse,
ein Multifunktionsdrucker.
Heute Morgen geht's dann
mit dem Frühstück an den Rechner.
Heute ist Vorlesungstag.
Das bedeutet,
wir müssen um 10 Uhr
die erste Veranstaltung halten.
Das muss ich mir anschauen.
Was ich jetzt die nächsten
eineinhalb Stunden mit meinen Studierenden
machen werde.
Ja, das kann man sich ja eine Stunde vorher
mal angucken, was man erzählt.
Ich hab mal alles gefühlt.
Erst mal ist man Lehrender für die Studierenden.
Man muss ihnen alles an Wissen zu vermitteln,
was sie für die juristischen Staatsexamina brauchen.
Und man hat einen zweiten Teil,
der eben mit der Professorentätigkeit verbunden ist.
Das ist die Forschung.
Also Lehre und Forschung gehen Hand in Hand.
Sollen auch ungefähr gleiches Gewicht ausmachen.
Und das heißt, man untersucht halt
rechtliche Probleme,
wettet sie aus.
Gut, dann gucke ich auf die Uhr,
stelle fest, es ist schon recht spät.
Ein paar Löffelchen noch und dann flitzen wir los.
Aber gutes Monitor-Setup.
Gut, gut.
Auf dem Setway fahren ist ein Gefühl von
Schweben und Freiheit.
Für die kurze Strecke, das sind ungefähr vier Kilometer mit dem Auto,
macht keinen Sinn, mit dem Auto zu fahren.
Es ist wie immer mit dem Segway.
Man hat, ich sag mal, 50% der Leute, die finden,
Segway?
Segway, gibt's das überhaupt noch?
Ist das...
Warte mal, war Segway nicht die Dinger,
wo der Gründer aus Versehen mit dem Segway
die Klippe runtergefahren ist?
Und irgendwie danach wollte nie jemand Segways kaufen?
Heute haben die ja alle Elektroroller.
Ja, cool.
Manche Leute denken, was ist das denn?
Ein Spinner?
Das kann man definitiv auch im Gesicht sehen.
Ja gut, man könnte sich einfach
eine Elektroroller heutzutage holen.
Aber solange man so ein Teil noch hat...
Der fährt einfach in der Uni da rum.
Easy.
Direkt ins Büro gefahren.
25 Minuten Vorlesungsbeginn.
Gucken wir mal nach.
Wir brauchen noch die Folien,
die wir vorbereitet haben.
Na, Helm sieht ja auch nicht gut aus
zu Anzug.
Das geht ja nicht.
Presenter.
So.
Mein Vater hat mir mal früher
einen Flow ins Ohr gesetzt,
dass Anwälte viel Geld verdienen
und wenig arbeiten würden
und dicke Autos fahren würden.
Und diesem Irrglauben war ich als Kind erlegen
und wollte nach dem Jura studieren.
Der Weg des Universitätsprofessors
war dann tatsächlich über die Phase der Promotion,
und da muss man einfach sagen,
da habe ich Blut geleckt.
Das hat mir so viel Freude bereitet
und die Resonanz und das Feedback
war so überwältigend gut,
das musste ich weitermachen.
Da war ich ein Stück weit süchtig nach,
wenn man das mal so sagen darf.
Heute haben wir etwas...
Lehrer sein ist wirklich
eines der schlimmsten Sachen,
die ich mir vorstellen kann.
Aber an der Uni geht es vielleicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber die ist nicht ganz so lebendig,
kann man nicht ganz so schön
Edutainment machen.
Wenn man eine Information mit einer Emotion koppelt,
wird man sich Ewigkeiten daran erinnern.
Und wenn ich jetzt irgendeinen blöden Witz
oder einen dummen Spruch trinke
und die Studierenden lachen,
haben sie eine Emotion,
die verbinden dann diese Information
mit der Emotion, dann bleibt die getriggert.
Ich denke mal, ich habe alles dabei.
Also immer Dummsprüche machen.
Wir haben heute einen kleinen Hörsaal
und die ersten ein, zwei Termine
ist man etwas mehr nervös,
weil man eben noch nicht weiß,
wie wird die Veranstaltung ankommen,
wie ist die Gruppe dort.
Heute haben wir für diese Veranstaltung
den zweiten Termin.
Das heißt also auch noch relativ junge
Dozenten-Zuhörerschaft-Beziehungen.
Das heißt, da müssen wir erstmal noch gucken.
So, Dille. Hallo.
Hallo, darf ich schon übernehmen?
Ja, klar, gerne.
Dann schalten wir mal die Technik hier ein.
Beide Beamer.
Die Zimmer sehen teilweise echt immer aus,
wie als wären sie,
na gut, ich wollte gerade sagen,
wie vor 100 Jahren gebaut,
aber wahrscheinlich sind sie auch vor 100 Jahren gebaut.
Das sind immer so nackige Räuber.
Einen schönen guten Tag.
Ich darf Sie ganz herzlich zu unserem
zweiten Termin begrüßen.
Wir haben im ersten Termin
so ein bisschen die Einleitung gemacht
zu der Veranstaltung.
Das heißt, warum gibt es diese Veranstaltung
und in welchen Bereichen hat sich das entwickelt.
Antidiskriminierungsrecht.
Aha.
55 Stunden pro Woche.
Nicht schlecht.
Dass ich jetzt endlich Sie mittelbar
diskriminieren möchte oder benachteiligen möchte,
ist Folgendes.
Wenn man die Information mit einer Emotion koppelt,
wird man sich Ewigkeiten daran erinnern.
Ich werfe hierher auf den Tisch,
das prallt ab und trifft Sie dann.
Das heißt, ich ziele auf ein anderes Merkmal als ein solches,
was einst nach dem AGG ist,
aber die Wirkung wird Sie
genauso treffen, weil der Zusammenhang
zwischen Ihnen und dem Merkmal...
Der Typ denkt sich jetzt,
Alter, lass mich in Ruhe.
Kannst du das nicht mit irgendjemand anderem demonstrieren?
Muss ich das jetzt echt sein?
Der wird sich das nicht merken.
...so stark ist, dass es Sie betrifft.
Machen wir einfach einen Fall,
den Sie auch schon mal hatten.
Ich möchte jemanden einstellen,
der tatsächlich nur
nachmittags arbeitet.
Statistisch gesehen wird die Kindererziehung
in Deutschland überwiegend von Damen wahrgenommen.
Statistisch rein nur.
Und aufgrund dessen können die Frauen dann schlechter,
weil sie am Nachmittag niemanden hat,
der die Kinder betreut,
wenn dann benachteiligt.
Das heißt, das Merkmal Nachmittagstätigkeit
ist eigentlich geschlechtsneutral.
Das hat mit dem Merkmal Geschlecht
nichts zu tun.
Durch den statistischen Zusammenhang
wird aber eine mittelbare Benachteiligung
von Damen daraus.
Ich bedanke mich für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Bis nächste Woche. Bleiben Sie gesund.
Ich muss sagen,
der Professor in der Schule
macht das jetzt nur,
weil er weiß, dass er aufgezeichnet wird?
Was soll er sagen?
Ich kann meinen Professor überhaupt nicht ab!
Wobei ich könnte mir ohne Scheiß
davon abhängen, was er anders sagen soll.
Aber ich glaube,
ganz ehrlich,
der Vortrag wirkte auf mich,
als wäre es tatsächlich spannend zuzuhören.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er schlecht ist.
Was soll er anderes sagen?
Er schafft es,
diese systematischen Themen uns auch mit Humor beizubringen, zum Beispiel jetzt auch mit den
Beispielen hier, wo er mich wohl abgeworfen hat. Das ist eine einfache, aber auch zielbringende
Darstellung. Ja, hat eigentlich wie immer Spaß gemacht. Ist immer wieder schön. Aber da siehst
du was, das ist jemand, der hört sich selbst gerne reden und du musst auch jemand sein,
dass du sowas machen kannst. Wenn du selbst da keinen Bock drauf hast, dann wird das nichts.
Du musst dich selber schon irgendwie cool finden und gerne reden hören. Anders kannst du was,
glaube ich, nicht machen. Und sonst, das wirkt dann auch nicht überzeugend. Also,
die sind immer super billig dabei mit Essen. Ich muss allein schon 10 Euro am Tag ausgeben,
wenn ich das so mache. Das ist einfach so. Das ist einfach so. Das ist einfach so. Das ist einfach so.
In Frankfurt 75 Euro monatlich. Fuck, Mann, das ist ja nichts. Also, wenn ich in Frankfurt
essen gehen würde, könnte ich locker am Tag 10 Euro ausgeben, nur für Essen. Mach ich ja nicht.
Also, ich nehme ja meistens mittlerweile sogar was mit, weil es mir zu teuer ist.
Ich habe mir ja hier auch eine Motivationswand hingebaut. Ich weiß nicht.
Oh, nee, please.
Ist von How I Met Your Mother. Es gibt eine Figur, die heißt Barney. Barney Swensen. Sie
hat sich damals so eine Motivationswand gebaut, eine ganz schöne.
schönen Sprüchen und Bildern.
Jeder, was ihm gefällt.
Und dann ist man auch schon motiviert und gut gelaunt.
Ich dachte erst, hier auf den ersten
Blick, das wäre das MW2-Cover.
Ist es aber nicht.
Es kommt wahrscheinlich noch raus, dass es Lance Armstrong
da oben war.
Ja, jetzt haben wir ungefähr noch eine Dreiviertelstunde
bis zur Vorlesung. Wir werden im
BGB-AT sein und dann werden wir so ein bisschen
die Grundlagen auch Anfang des Semesters
legen und dann erklären, was sind Sachen,
was sind Rechte,
wie kann man die zuordnen,
wie stehen die Sachen zueinander.
Das kann schon mal sein.
Es passiert aber sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr selten,
dass die Technik da einen im Stich lässt
und dann stellt man sich die Frage... Warum gammeln die eigentlich
da vorne rum und sitzen da nicht hinten?
... man gerade selber unfähig
oder liegt es an der Technik?
Sind das die Schleimer,
die früher auch Tasche getragen haben, oder?
Ich glaube, heutzutage muss keiner
mehr dem Professor helfen, die Technik anzuschließen.
Oder?
Also bei uns in der Schule war ja
Video und
generell Technik immer...
Ach so, das sind gar keine
Studenten.
Es funktioniert tatsächlich etwas nicht.
Das ist dann schon mal so.
Erstmal, ah, der eine Beamer geht nicht an.
Beide Beamer gehen nicht an, das ist irritierend.
Jetzt haben wir noch zwei Minuten in der Hoffnung,
dass wir das fixen können.
Wie Sie sehen, sehen Sie nichts.
Das ist...
Ja, da würde ich auch ein bisschen nervös werden.
Ah.
Das ist daran nicht...
Der Strom ist nicht an.
Aha.
Da hat mir doch irgendjemand den Strom abgedreht.
In der Hoffnung, dass da jetzt was kommt.
Mhm.
Sieht gut aus.
Der wollte den Trollen, der Typ davor wahrscheinlich.
Der hat gesagt, bevor ich rausgehe,
schalte ich dem einfach nochmal
den Strom ab.
Schönen guten Tag.
Ich darf Sie ganz herzlich zu unserem
5. Session begrüßen.
Der Weg war steinig.
Universitätsprofessoren gibt es eben sehr, sehr wenige.
Wenige Stellen.
Viele Leute, die dieses gerne erreichen wollen.
Weil man ein paar Vorteile auch damit hat.
Insbesondere, dass man natürlich verbeamtet ist.
Dass man Forschung und Lehre betreiben darf.
Und das hat eben auch ein Stück weit
ein gewisses Renommee in der Gesellschaft.
Und deshalb möchten das viele machen.
Das heißt, man weiß es.
Leute, der hat tatsächlich was gearbeitet
von morgens bis jetzt mittags.
Was ist denn da los?
Der hat gearbeitet, hat gegessen, hat gearbeitet.
Da gibt es ja tatsächlich Leute,
die arbeiten noch was.
Ähm.
Makario, danke für den Sub.
Wir sehen uns hoffentlich übermorgen
in alter Frische wieder. Bleiben Sie gesund.
Sagte mal, warum klatschen eigentlich alle,
außer Studenten, die klopfen auf den Tisch?
Die erste Tageshilfe ist jetzt rum.
Ja gut, um 17 Uhr die erste Tageshilfe rum.
Klingt komisch, aber
das ist der Lehrteil jetzt vorbei.
Jetzt darf ich mich an den Forschungsteil begeben.
Tradition.
Jetzt bin ich ab nach Hause.
Weil das so gemacht wird.
Ja, ich weiß, aber warum?
Wenn das mal wieder sinkt.
Ist ja quer rumgedüst.
Ja, die Plebs klatschen,
die die High-IQ-Leute klopfen.
Amtler hat man eine private Krankenversicherung,
die man abziehen muss.
Das sind dann also nach Abzug der Krankenkasse
ungefähr 4,4.
Zufrieden mit dem Gehalt.
Ich habe alles.
Oh, da geht schon was.
Was ich brauche und brauche nicht mehr.
Das ist das eine, was man sagen kann.
Wenn ich aber bedenke,
was ich bereits als Berufseinsteiger
vielleicht hätte verdienen können,
ohne Doktortitel und ohne Habilitation,
das heißt,
mit neun Jahren Ausbildung weniger,
da hätte ich einen Einstiegsgehalt gehabt,
Angebote gehabt von Düsseldorfer Kanzleien
von 120.000 Euro brutto im Jahr.
Da hätte er aber auch nicht das machen können,
worauf er Bock hat.
Also wahrscheinlich ist das schon
wie eine gute Kombination.
Jetzt kommt dann eben auch der Forschungsteil.
Und ja, da steht es jetzt erst mal
als nächstes erst mal prioritär an.
Produktearbeit, die mir in Ehe...
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
es sind auch 55 Stunden die Woche.
Habe ich ganz vergessen.
Es sind 55 Stunden die Woche.
Dann ist das dann relativiert sich das schon wieder.
Mitarbeiter eingereicht hat zu lesen, korrigieren,
Änderungsvorschläge zu machen, zu betreuen.
Es bleibt nicht so viel in der Freizeit, sage ich ganz ehrlich.
Also mir ist es natürlich wichtig,
dass ich zu Familie und Freunden Kontakt halte,
weil das ist sozusagen natürlich das Emoji.
Überlegt euch mal 55 Stunden die Woche.
Das sind das sind elf Stunden am Tag.
Oder weiß ich, ob die Samstag sauber machen?
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist aber schon ordentlich.
Ja, gerade 55 ist wirklich heftig.
Tatsächlich täglich mit meinem Vater.
Ansonsten reise ich gerne.
Ich fotografiere wahnsinnig gerne.
Es bleibt eigentlich nicht viel Zeit dafür,
außer während des Reisens überall in der Wohnung.
Aber wisst ihr, was auch sein kann?
Dass das über das Jahr über das Jahr gar nicht,
gar nicht so viel mehr ist,
weil die haben bestimmt doch auch Pausen und Ferien.
Und da, wo einer Uni nichts läuft, oder?
Das ist doch.
Das ist doch wahrscheinlich umgerechnet so,
dass es im Schnitt wieder halbwegs normal ist.
Da forscht er die schönsten Bilder meiner Reisen
irgendwo auf die Wand gehauen oder ausgedruckt oder so.
Ich wohne hier in Augsburg,
weil es nicht weit von der Uni weg ist.
Hier kommen wir knapp irgendwas Kilometer.
Kann man im Segway gut fahren.
Hab mir da.
Er mag sein Segway auf jeden Fall zugelegt.
Was heißt hier klein?
86 Quadratmeter ist nicht klein.
Und da habe ich mich einfach ausgebreitet,
fühle mich heimisch und wohl.
Das war es von meiner Seite.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt ein bisschen Spaß.
Interessantes Video.
Zumindest zumindest habe ich bei ihm wirklich das Gefühl gehabt,
der mag seinen Job.
Der findet das toll.
Natürlich findet er sich selbst toll und hört sich selbst gerne reden.
Aber das musst du in der Position auch ran.
Das geht das gar nicht.
Und ich kann euch noch empfehlen.
Hier seht ihr auf der Seite noch ein paar Informationen zu Recht,
aber als Fachangestellten und hier noch noch weitere Videos.
Das heißt, schaut rein.
Format gefällt mir ganz gut.
Vielleicht euch ja auch weiterhin.
Da ist es.
Das finde ich immer ganz interessant.
Triple Monitor Elgato Stream Deck.
Ja, so muss das sein.
Ich sage euch so haben wir noch irgendwas Spannendes.
Also eigentlich habe ich richtig Kohlabf mittlerweile,
aber ich warte noch.
Komm, halbe Stunde oder so.
Kurz nach zwölf mache ich was zu essen.
Online Vorlesung einfach auf Twitch streamen und auf Sub hoffen.
Gute Idee.
Wo werden denn Online Vorlesungen gestreamt?
Haben die da haben die da eigene Portale bei der Uni?
Oder gibt es auch Leute, die das einfach auf YouTube oder Twitch streamen?
Weil was Geheimes ist es ja nicht.
Zoom.
Ich meine, die bessere Bildqualität hätte Twitch und YouTube auf jeden Fall als Teams.
YouTube und Twitch ist qualitativ auf jeden Fall besser als Zoom oder Teams.
Zoom.
Das ist ja nichts Geheimes.
Theoretisch könnte man das auch machen.
Theoretisch könnte man das auch einfach Public streamen auf Twitch.
Warum nicht?
Skype.
Um das sehen zu dürfen.
Warum eigentlich?
Ich meine.
Wo ist das Problem?
Wenn es jeder sehen darf.
Stimmt.
Ja gut, wenn du das Publikum streamst, ist das was anderes.
Aber du musst ja nicht das Publikum streamen.
Vortrag an Stream.
Ja, ein paar Fragen ist tatsächlich schwieriger.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Ja, okay, das das das leuchtet mir.
Klingt plausibel.
Jetzt haben wir mal ein paar Fragen.
Was ist das Problem?
Was habt ihr?
Ich finde, ich finde das.
Ist jetzt nicht mehr gibbar.
Leuchtet das Problem?
Das ist ja weniger plausibel.
Sag mal was hat man sonst noch?
Ne, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Fireship Video!
Nimm in 100 Sekunden!
Okay, komm, Fireship.
Fireship ist immer POG.
Die einzige General Purpose System Programming
Language das geben darf ist Rust weil nur Rust ist Blazingly Fast.
... High Performance Native Apps, with concise, elegant
It was created by Andreas Rumpf in Germany in 2005, who wanted a language with the performance of C, the productivity of Python, and the extensibility of Lisp.
Like other systems languages, MIM is statically typed and compiled.
However, it's unique because its source code is first translated to a different language, usually C, then uses a compiler like Clang to convert it to machine code.
And it can also transpile to C++, Objective-C, and even JavaScript.
By default, it uses a deterministic memory management strategy based on reference counting, but this behavior can be customized or removed altogether, allowing low-level control over memory with pointers.
Syntactically, it feels like a statically typed Python, but it also provides extensive support for metaprogramming with a macro system that allows direct access to the abstract syntax tree,
allowing you to mold the language to your exact needs, much like the Lisp family of languages.
To get started, install it on your machine, then create a new file ending in .NIM.
Unlike C, no main function is necessary.
Use echo to print to the standard output, or create a variable with the var keyword, and follow it with an optional type annotation.
Variables can be reassigned, but we can make them single assignment with let, or use const to make the assigned value immutable.
When writing a complex statement like an if-condition, indentation matters like Python.
This keeps the code nice and readable, like when declaring multiple variables.
For loops, it has a...
I mean, I know this is an example, but you could have just written c="b", or c="not b", then you could have saved that, but okay, that's an example, as I said, he knows that.
It has a variety of built-in iterators, like countup and countdown, or you can use the iterator keyword along with yield to build your own from scratch.
To define functions or methods, we use procedures, which can take input.
Arguments and return a value.
It also supports closures and using procedures as arguments or return values for functional programming patterns.
However, it's also possible to use object-oriented patterns by first creating a complex type, which can then be instantiated like a class.
And it also supports generics, allowing you to use types as parameters.
Okay, die Generik-Syntax ist schon wieder komisch.
...really special though, is its support for metaprogramming.
For example, we can get the abstract syntax tree at any time using dump tree.
Okay, das ist Lisp-Gedöns jetzt.
...we can now write our own macros, which are like functions that modify the abstract syntax tree at compile time.
Okay, das ist jetzt irgendein...
Was für Lisp-Fans.
...now open the terminal and use the compiler to convert your NIM-Code into C and then into a machine code executable, or use the JS-Command to transpile...
Was heißt...
Jetzt mal eine blöde Frage, ne?
Wenn ich NIM einfach nach C transpilen kann, dann könnte ich theoretisch einen Microcontroller mit NIM programmieren.
...wenn ich NIM einfach nach C transpilen kann, dann könnte ich theoretisch einen Microcontroller mit NIM programmieren.
...to javascript.
This has been NIM in 100 seconds.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob du in NIM C-Header importieren kannst und sowas, dass du das aufrufen kannst.
Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
Das ist aber keine Sprache, die mich irgendwie großartig interessiert.
Also ich muss sagen, dass von so den ganzen Sprachen, die so in letzter Zeit ein bisschen Hype hatten, muss ich sagen, dass ich SIG relativ interessant finde.
Aber auch nicht interessant genug, dass ich damit großartig was machen würde.
Ich finde die Idee dahinter ganz gut.
Die sagen, C++ sagt, wir brauchen was Besseres.
So nach dem Motto.
Aber ansonsten.
Ja gut, es gibt ja immer noch Carbon von Google.
Wobei ich glaube nicht, dass sich das durchsetzen wird.
Wadabum Dingsbums.
Wadabum.
27 Monate.
Dankeschön.
Massive Subscription.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Nice.
Das ist das Häkchen jetzt zu kaufen geben soll.
Und dass Elon irgendwie 50% der Leute entlassen hat.
Und dass ganz viele Leute jetzt geflüchtet sind schon von Twitter.
So nach dem Motto.
Oh nein.
Das geht ja hier nicht.
Und dann frage ich mich halt, wohin wollen sie denn flüchten?
Es gibt ja nichts Vergleichbares zu Twitter.
Also.
Ja, da habe ich vorhin schon was drüber gesagt.
Ansonsten.
Mastadon, da ist doch niemand.
Zu Nitter.
Das ist doch nicht so.
Keine Alternative.
Da ist doch keiner.
Ne.
Also.
Ich bin gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt.
Ich sehe keinen Grund für mich jetzt erstmal Twitter nicht zu verwenden.
Mal gucken, was da noch kommt.
Ganz ehrlich.
Wenn es total abkackt.
Wird es irgendeine sinnige Alternative zu geben.
Und es wird wahrscheinlich nicht Mastadon oder so sein.
Sondern es wird wahrscheinlich irgendwas Neues sein.
Wo die Leute dann drauf aufspringen.
Aber.
Ich sehe jetzt auch noch nicht den großen Untergang.
Auf von Twitter, ehrlich gesagt.
Twitter darfst machen eine neue Bude auf.
Ja, sollen sie mal machen.
Also.
Mal abwarten.
Bin gespannt, was, wie sich das entwickelt.
Ich persönlich mag Twitter.
Für mich ist.
Also ich finde, Twitter ist das Beste.
Es ist ja kein richtiges Social Netzwerk, was an Mastadon so schlecht ist.
Gar nichts.
Benutzt halt kaum einer.
Ich finde, Twitter ist immer noch das beste Social Network, wenn man es so nennen kann.
Was ist die Alternative denn?
Facebook oder Instagram, Tiktok rein für Textmessages und also ohne Mist für so Security News und und und schnell Sachen mitbekommen, was gerade passiert ist.
Twitter das Beste, was es gibt.
Ja, Telegram, da kannst du zum Wendler in die Gruppe gehen.
Ja, weiß, aber Telegram ist ja ein Instant Messenger eher eher weniger so ein Public Ding, wie ich weiß, du kannst Gruppen machen und so.
Also ich.
Also ich mir mir fällt keine sinnvolle Alternative aktuell ein zu Twitter ja und selbst Hacker News verlinkt öfters auf Twitter also insofern ich denke nicht, dass Twitter bald weg sein wird in einem Jahr schließen die also ich glaube nicht, dass der wirklich ein Interesse daran hat, Twitter zu schließen in einem Jahr so viel wie das gekostet hat, zumal er das ja irgendwie, glaube ich, auch per Kredit mitfinanziert hat.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass der wirklich ein Interesse daran hat, Twitter zu schließen in einem Jahr so viel wie das gekostet hat, zumal er das ja irgendwie, glaube ich, auch per Kredit mitfinanziert hat.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass der wirklich ein Interesse daran hat, Twitter zu schließen in einem Jahr schließen die so viel wie das gekostet hat, zumal er das gekostet hat, zumal er das gekostet hat, zumal er das gekostet hat, zumal er das gekostet hat,remember von миллиard yolk nimmt das jetzt wieder ab.
JOG
Ja, das finde ich auch richtig P inning ja, dass das habe ich auch gelesen so nach dem Motto Jeder, Jeder darf sagen und machen, was er will.
Aber wenn einer sein Werbevertrag.
Milliarden, Millionen wär ja noch
kein Ding, ja.
Das bezahlt er nebenbei mal.
Also ich find Twitter gut.
Für mich ist Twitter
das beste Social-Network, was es gibt.
Was halt an Twitter
ein bisschen nervig ist, ist, dass da halt
so viele selbst, wie soll man sagen,
so sich selbst bestätigende
Leute unterwegs sind, ja, also
die quasi
immer den ganzen Tag Bestätigung brauchen,
dass sie gute Menschen sind, so, und dann
die sich
quasi untereinander den ganzen Tag auf die Schulter
kloppen und so sagen, ja, ja, so ist das gut,
so ist das richtig. Ja, die anderen sind doof, aber
wir, wir sind die, wir sind die Tollen.
Da ist Twitter ganz groß drin.
So aus allen Lagern
machen das da viele gerne auf Twitter.
Ja, die Millionen
wären ihm vielleicht fast aus der Tasche gefallen.
Dollarvergleich, ja, nice.
Das ist der
dümmste Tweet zum Thema, weiß nicht, ob ich das aufmachen
soll. Naja, Leute, ich
hab Hunger, ich glaub, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Es ist 12.
Massive
People Fat Time.
Was hat man sonst noch? Bad Kid Time?
Nee, nee.
Press Time.
Also, Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.